monsieur bolloré c'est peu dire que
votre audition est très attendu bien
entendu par les membres de la commission
mais aussi
en dehors votre groupe et est devenu en
peu d'années un acteur majeur du paysage
médiatique avec d'ores et déjà et sans
être exhaustif des entités comme canal+
et ses news dans l'audiovisuel paris
match le jdd et les magazines du groupe
prisma dans la presse europe 1 dans la
radio editis et achètent dans d'édition
pagny g dans la production et havas
temps la publicité je pense que le
rapporteur reviendra sur les différentes
entités de votre groupe lempereur
l'ampleur prise sous votre direction par
vivant dit dans les médias entre donc
pleinement dans le champ de notre
commission denquête elle renvoie à des
interrogations que nous nous posons sur
les conséquences de cette concentration
mais aussi sur l'efficacité des cars de
fou législatif existant ou à créer pour
tenir compte des logiques économiques
tout en assurant le respect du
pluralisme je ne vous surprendrai pas en
vous disant que votre nom revient de
manière très régulière dans les
auditions que nous avons menées jusqu'à
présent sans doute ceci est lié à la
façon dont vous concevez votre rôle
d'actionnaires sensiblement différent de
celui des autres grands capitaines
d'industrie qui comme vous ont investi
dans les médias avec un
interventionnisme sans doute plus
assumer un management très directif
c'est aussi liée au positionnement prix
par ses new skies n'est pas le plus
important des médias détenus par vivendi
en termes de chiffre d'affaires ou de
part d'audience mais qui est
certainement celui dont on parle le plus
depuis que sa ligne éditoriale de la
fait entrer d'après de nombreux
observateurs dans le champ des médias
d'opinion la commission a donc souhaité
vous donner la possibilité de vous
exprimer directement pour nous donner
votre vision de grands actionnaires des
médias à la fois sur la dépendance mais
également sur l'avenir d'un secteur en
bonne partie fragilisé par l'arrivée des
géants
du numérique je vous propose
l'organisation suivante qui est
d'ailleurs celle que nous avons bien en
place pour toutes nos auditions je vais
vous laisser la parole pour dix minutes
2-2 propos introductif je serai strict
sur le respect du temps de parole non
pas pour brimer votre expression mais
tout simplement pour permettre qu'après
nous ayons un dialogue à travers des
questions et des réponses avec les
sénatrices et sénateurs de la commission
ce sera le rapporteur qui commencera la
première série de questions je rappelle
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié enfin je rappelle pour la
forme qu un faux témoignage devant notre
commission denquête seraient passibles
des peines prévues aux articles 434 13
14 et 15 du code pénal je vous précise
également qu'il vous appartient le cas
échéant d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts en
relation avec l'objet de la commission
denquête et enfin comme nous sommes un
commission denquête je vais vous inviter
monsieur bolloré a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure merci monsieur bolloré je vous
laisse la parole pour dix minutes
on m'a demandé donc de dire quelques
mots de présentation
peut être rappeler rapidement mon
parcours je travaille depuis un peu plus
de 50 ans j'ai passé dix ans dans la
banque en terminant un dss de droit et
puis j'ai été appelé à passer
quarante ans dans une entreprise
industrielle fondée par ma famille près
de quimper en effet je suis né dans une
grande ancienne famille bretonne et
l'entreprise qu'elle dirige est est
tombé en difficulté j'ai donc été appelé
à quitter la banque pour mater au
redressement et au développement de
cette entreprise
quand je suis arrivée elle faisait 20
millions de chiffre d'affaires elle en
fait aujourd'hui 20 milliards elle
employait un peu moins de 800 personnes
et nous sommes un peu plus de 80000
personnes aujourd'hui dans le groupe
seul son siège social n'a pas bougé il
est toujours à ergué gabéric qui n'est
pas un paradis fiscal des antilles
néerlandaises de capa pour l'instant
mais un village à côté de quimper
mon travail est la clé de cette
croissance qui a été obtenu malgré des
crises économiques des problèmes des
pandémies comme en ce moment a consisté
pour le résumer à choisir recruter faire
travailler ensemble des personnes leur
donner les moyens du développement et
surtout à l'international et puis
évidemment insuffler le courage et
permettre aux équipes de travailler sur
le long terme car on s'aperçoit que les
actionnaires financiers souvent ont des
problèmes de court terme et on
s'aperçoit que quand on a la possibilité
de travailler sur le long terme les
choses se terminent mieux aujourd'hui
fini de laisser ma place de dirigeant ou
plutôt de conseillers puisque depuis
deux trois ans je suis passé de
dirigeants a conseillé j'ai la chance
d'avoir ma famille qui acceptait de
poursuivre cette saga industrielle et
qui va représenter la septième
génération elle s'investit à fond avec
évidemment des équipes dirigeantes de
grande qualité qui s'entendent avec eux
en ce qui concerne la partie du groupe
qui vous intéresse c'est à dire les
médias c'est le même chemin que je vous
ai décrit que nous avons fait d'abord
c'est un chemin que nous avons entrepris
il ya vingt ans
les gens parlent depuis peu de temps
mais ça fait 20 ans qu'on a commencé
avec une stratégie claire qui était dire
au fond qu'il existe un vivier de
contenus très important à partir de
notre culture française européenne et
qu'à côté
du soft power américain de tous ces
contenus qui viennent
d'amérique et qui songe à les dire
toujours à peu près les mêmes à côté des
contenus asiatiques qui arrivent de plus
en plus et bien les contenus européen
apporte une certaine fraîcheur qui est
sans doute extrêmement intéressante non
seulement à conserver pour le respect de
notre passé mais surtout à exporter et
donc c'est à partir de cette idée qui
était que nous pouvons créer un champion
de la culture européenne un champion de
la culture française que nous avons
entamé ce chemin il à 20 ans
c'est un secteur contrairement à ce que
croient les gens qui peut garder gagner
beaucoup d'argent c'est le deuxième
secteur le plus rentable dans le monde
après le luxe j'ai toute une série de
slide que je pourrais vous montrer tout
à l'heure si si vous le souhaitez si
vous en avez besoin
mais donc notre stratégie la culture
française la culture européenne face à
la culture américaine et asiatique des
équipes que nous avons recruté au fur et
à mesure de ses 20 ans jean christophe
thiery que vous connaissez qui nous a
rejoint des premiers avec philippe labro
et puis toute une équipe toute une série
de gens qui nous ont rejoint maxime
saada que vous allez recevoir deux croit
évidemment à nos puits fontaines et
plein d'autres et puis nous nous sommes
donné les moyens d'agir sur le long
terme
contrairement à ce qui est écrit un peu
partout
nous sommes encore tout petit nous
progressons c'est vrai mais nous sommes
encore tout petit et je vous montrerai
tout à l'heure si vous le souhaitez des
tableaux qui montre comme nous sommes
petits et en dehors du fait savoir si
les autres sont plus grands tout cas ce
qu'on peut regarder c'est que le vix
20-10 d'aujourd'hui est infiniment plus
petit que le vix 20 10 10 à 20 ans et
qui à l'époque en tout cas ne posait
aucun problème
voilà donc je suis à votre disposition
j'espère avoir respecté les dix minutes
pour répondre à vos questions j'indique
simplement que je réponds à titre
individuel puisque je n'ai aucun titre
ni pouvoir à la tête du groupe i 20 10
du groupe bolloré du groupe canal et
encore moins du groupe lagardère mais
bien évidemment je m'exprime à titre
individuel semble dérobé à la moindre
des questions que vous souhaiteriez me
poser
merci nous allons sans plus tarder
commencer les questions avec celle du
rapporteur david assouline
bonjour monsieur bolloré bonne année
notre commission denquête veut mettre en
lumière la réalité du paysage
audiovisuel et de la presse dans notre
pays
les phénomènes de concentration qui se
développe
comprendre leurs motivations
et analyser l'impact que cela peut avoir
sur le secteur économique mais aussi et
surtout sur l'exercice de la démocratie
du pluralisme de la liberté de
l'indépendance des médias qui sont des
principes inscrits à la constitution
dans la constitution d'ailleurs depuis
que je permis de l'amendé dans ce sens
au cours de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
ces principes sont à l'article 34
votre témoignage est tout à fait
important pour nous nécessaire attendu
parce que vous êtes devenu un acteur
important dans cette concentration
vos activités d'origine vous en avez
parlé mais c'est bien pour savoir de
quoi on parle
de deux
d'énumérer
les activités de votre groupe d'origine
essentiel
dans les transports et la logistique
fret maritime terrestre ou aérien les
opérations douanières les concessions
portuaires dont une présence dans 42
port et 17 concession de terminaux à
conteneurs en après que la distribution
d'énergie logistique pétrolière et
disparus distribution de produits
pétroliers
le chemin de fer transports de passagers
mais aussi maintenance et on peut dire
aussi que avec la fabrication de films
plastiques de solutions de stockage de
batterie de mobilité électronique
avec aussi une activité à travers ce aux
fins
de l'un des principaux planteurs dans le
monde avec près de 200 mille hectares de
palmiers à huile à l'eas en asie en
afrique principalement au cameroun au
nigeria au liberia
à partir de là vous l'avez signalé ce
n'est pas nouveau dans les années 2000
vous avez commencé plutôt timidement au
début à aller dans le secteur des médias
dans les années 2010 au milieu vous avez
accélérer ce mouvement est aujourd'hui
dans les derniers mois des opérations
encore de grande envergure au lieu et ce
qu'ils ont fait souvent l'actualité
pour que l'on comprenne de quoi on parle
g je vais énumérer
ça peut être fastidieux mais ça donne la
dimension de pourquoi vous êtes là
devant nous alors que nous parlons
justement de la concentration dans les
médias avec les groupes où vous avez
100% il y à ses huit ses stars ses news
studiocanal mail canal canal vod canal+
règle la chaîne canal toutes ses
variantes canal+ cinéma canal+ sport
séries etc car plus vietnam cas peluche
ex canalsat canal international
calédonie canal+ caraïbes canal+ réunion
canal+ rick vous avez aussi les multi
thématiques s'il n'est plus planète
téléthon pee wee foot+ comédie infosport
saison olympia tv cana plus polska
canal+ meehan marc aymes 7 avec télésat
etc et vous avez aussi dans les jeux
vidéo
et dans le monde des métiers du
spectacle vivant de la billetterie des
festivals et de la production citic est
info conserve c'est parce copyright
group live théâtre de l'oeuvre vivendi
sport can à l'olympia l'olympia vie
lundi bang marketing dans le monde
encore où vous êtes à 100% de la
publicité on va dire havas créative
arena médias renold l'institut csa
l'institut de sondage bt cbtc fusil l'x
et je vais passer toutes les filiales
davasse qui sont très importantes en
france et partout dans le monde encore à
100% la plateforme d'hébergement de
vidéos dailymotion
et puis le groupe prisma médias dans le
domaine des magazines et d'édition ça
m'intéresse capital cuisine actuelle
femme actuelle femme actuelle seniors
flow gala géo harvard business review
management national geographic néons
prix pris ma télé loisirs télé 2
semaines tv jantes voici vous france
catholique dans le domaine de l'édition
de la presse l'hebdomadaire et vous avez
baissé en
capital mais vous êtes participants
encore dans universal music group qui
est le premier label de musique au monde
et puis
vous avez aussi des maisons d'édition et
18 avec force des forces interactive
dans la collection pour les nuls round
les livres du dragon d'or tana cuisine
loisirs créatifs voyage écologie 404
édition les escales et les escales
domaine français l'one lonely planet
france est ma langue au chat éditions
solar poulpe fiction slalom livre
jeunesse vous avez la main on place des
éditeurs avec plomb et presses de la
renaissance éditions perrin éditions
belfond éditions omnibus hors collection
presses de la cité vous avez le groupe
robert laffont avec les éditions robert
laffont les éditions julliard nil
éditions éditions seghers vous avez dans
l'univers des poches les 10-18 fleuve
éditions kurokawa pocket et pocket
jeunesse 12 21 l'éditeur numérique
d'autres maisons d'édition celle du
cherche midi la découverte sonatine
éditions
xo éditions éditions héloïse d'ormesson
éditions télémaque et
aujourd'hui vous êtes à 49 45 18 13 %
dans le groupe lagardère
avec nous paie acp qui est
imminente dans le mois qui va nous
suivre et là vous êtes à europe 1 rfm
virgin radio paris match journal du
dimanche le groupe hachette c'est armand
colin les éditions albert rené
calmann-lévy des sagnes et aura les
taulards à des scènes et tolra de coqs
d'or du no edicef édifiant ce et 10 et
des éditions des deux terres éditions du
chêne éditions stock éditions fayard
éditions mille et une nuits l'édition
mazarine pauvert grasset grasset
jeunesse édition fasquelle bibliothèque
charpentier gauthier l'achète à hachette
édition
indications pardon achète français
langue étrangère à cette jeunesse
hachette pratique achète roman hachette
tourisme avec le guide du routard
éditions hazan harlequins arabe groupe
alexandre hatier heads l intérêt dition
istra
lattès larousse le livre de paris audio
l'ip le livre de poche marabout
microsoft press octopus france orbite
pika édition je vais pas énumérer vos
participations dans des médias étrangers
mais bon il y a prisa vous êtes un oeuf
une % dans quatre journaux et de radio
el país etc et puis aussi des médias 28
2% dans le secteur de la communication
trois chaînes de télévision italiennes
canal 5 italiens est un quatre et c'est
donc c'est de cela que l'on parle et
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
simple à la suite de cette énumération
pourquoi
constitué cet empire quel est votre
intérêt votre passion pour construire un
tel empire médiatique dans notre pays
je vais vous demander d'appuyer sur le
bar d'un taux pourtant historiquement
nous étions dans le papier je rajoute
ocb auquel nous tenons beaucoup comme
marc ristori si vous m'autorisez
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président je vais vous montrer je sais
pas si vous voyez bien sinon j'ai
quelques
documents
vous voyez bien si l'enjeu des documents
voilà ça c'est pour replacer vivent un
10 qui est le champion français voyez
c'est complètement à droite on le voit à
peine sont les capitalisations
boursières il y en a évidemment beaucoup
plus entre les deux mais entre nous et
nos concurrents voyez le petit vivendi
avec le drapeau français ces 15
milliards capitalisation boursière
sony ses 156 disney 287 tencent 586
apple de 1812 voilà ça c'est pour vous
montrer que le géant vie 20 10 en
réalité quand on regarde les choses
telles qu'elles sont et pas tel que on
voudrait les présenter c'est un petit
n'a ensuite si vous regardez le tableau
d'après vous vous apercevez que
peut-être en effet nous avons bougé dans
les dernières années et je vais revenir
à votre question évidemment qui est
pourquoi et comment mais vous voyez que
pendant que nous bougeons les
concurrents américains qui sont
infiniment plus grands bouge encore plus
vite et je parle pas des concurrents
asiatiques qui ont aussi bouge
extraordinairement vite
nous connaissons bien tencent et un
certain nombre de grands groupes et
leurs façons d'avancer foyer la dernière
opération c'est le fameux catalogue mgm
avec tous les films que vous avez vu qui
a été repris par amazon discovery et
puis encore ce matin la reprise de
activision blizzard par un grand groupe
américain si vous regardez le tableau
d'après
là on parle de canal en france voilà
canal en france c'est le cinquième
acteur du marché voilà nous faisons 6 3%
et encore grâce au succès récents sinon
nous étions un peu au dessous et vous
voyez que france tv c'est 28,8 tf1 26 9
l'a6 14,5 civile la fusion se fait ils
seront à 41 4 mais évidemment c'est la
fusion c'est on aura davantage de passer
à la quatrième place enfin pour
l'instant nous sommes tout petits à 6,3
sur ce qui fait le plus de papier de ce
que je peux voir c'est le segment de
l'information et là le tableau d'après
est encore intéressant puisqu'on voit en
nombre de téléspectateurs
la taille de ces news qui est la seule
partie information du groupe puisque
dans tout ce que vous avez cités canal
ne fait plus de journaux télévisés ni
aucune des autres chaînes du groupe et
vous voyez que grâce au succès récents
nous sommes à 1 millions en audience
moyenne
bfm et à 2,2 la 6 à 4 la 2 à 7 2 et tf1
9 millions ce sont des fêtes monsieur
rapporteur ce ne sont pas des
et propos le tableau d'après sur la
radio
ça concerne lagardère comme vous savez
nous attendons la commission européenne
est temps que la commission européenne
ne s'est pas prononcée nous ne pouvons
rien faire sur lagardère mais enfin
simplement de savoir que lagardère
aujourd'hui avec europe 1 c'est la
huitième place
france inter rtl nrj france bleu rmc
nostalgie info europe 1 monsieur bolloré
je vous interromps deux secondes juste
pour préciser j'ai oublié de le faire
j'aurais dû le dire d'ailleurs que nous
recevrons bien sûr tous les
propriétaires
nerfs des différents groupes biens
sociaux n'est on ne se ne parle pas que
de votre groupe quand on parle de
concentration on parle aussi d autres
mais on voit bien que le vôtre est en
phase ascendante ou en progression dans
la la croissance
vous avez raison de vous entendre bien
sûr mais recevront bien sûr tous les
responsables
je vous remercie de attendait fini juste
et trois en trois petits slide pour
terminer
la presse alors la presse nationale
payante quotidienne voyez le tableau que
vous avez sur la partie haute est bien
le groupe n'est aucunement présent ni
vivent un dîner un éventuel lagardère
qui viendrait s'ajouter à vivaldi et
quant à la presse du septième jour qui
est un sujet extrêmement important nous
sommes 1 2 3 4 5 6 le groupe lagardère
et 7e en france
après vous avez l'édition qui est un
sujet dont aussi tout le monde parle et
vous voyez cachette et 3e et editis et
bien nous sommes le 19e acteurs
et puis après vous avez une comparaison
européenne
entre vivendi et bertelsmann qui est un
concurrent allemand et vous voyez que
nous sommes là aussi plus de deux fois
plus petit 8 milliards 7 contre 10 7
milliards 3 et dernier slide je m'arrête
là surprendre et les autres plus tard
s'il ya besoin ça c'est le vix 20-10
d'aujourd'hui et c'est le vix 20-10
d'avant celui qui donc ne posait pas de
problème le vix 20-10 d'aujourd'hui
c'est comme celui d'avant avec canal+
havas ça n'a pas changé
editis appelé avant robert laffont
larousse vivent un deuil universal
publie chez c'est la même chose à la
place de gameloft qui avait
activision-blizzard
devenu un géant américain et vous aviez
le groupe express le groupe le point
l'usiné nouvelle des dizaines et des
dizaines de magazines qui était sous le
nom cep vous aviez le groupe de cinéma
et de production audiovisuelle
gc
vous aviez les studio américain
universal vous aviez sfr
l'immense groupe de télécommunications
qui appartient aujourd'hui
1 patrick drahi cegetel pagesjaunes as
well ce que je veux dire en d'autres
termes ce rapporteur c'est que
c'est vrai que nous avons grandi et
c'est vrai que je suis honoré d'être
reçu aujourd'hui au sénat dans le terme
de la concentration puisque quand vous
avez reçue il ya cinq ans c'était parce
que vous êtes tous trouvent très inquiet
enfin certains d'entre vous que canal+
deviennent canal - comme c'était
l'histoire qui était raconté à l'époque
et qu'au fond les 200 millions financé
le cinéma français allait-il pouvoir
être continuer à financer ou pas est
donc quelque part on s'éteint je vais
dire c'est un compliment qui est fait
quand on s'aperçoit finalement dans ces
cinq années nous avons progressé alors
pour répondre à votre question pourquoi
c'est uniquement un projet économique et
si vous regardez le slide numéro 11
c'est à dire 3 slide plus tard
voilà celui ci dans celui ci voit là
vous voyez que dans le monde le secteur
des médias c'est le deuxième secteur le
plus rentable après le luxe donc il ya
beaucoup de gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent dans les médias et donc notre
intérêt n'est pas politique n'est pas
idéologique c'est un intérêt purement
économique
et depuis vingt ans ce groupe s'est
constitué uniquement sur des questions
économiques et vous avez vu d'ailleurs
si c'était politique le segment de
l'information pour nous est un segment
absolument un signifiant à la fois en
chiffre d'affaires chez nous mais dans
le poids du pays c'était le slide que je
vous ai montré en numéro 3 ou 4 où on
s'aperçoit que nous sommes minuscule
alors
ça me permet de rebondir
sur ma deuxième question
personne ne conteste des réussites
économiques
personne ici ne jettera la pierre à 7
réussite économique le sujet est que
nous ne parlons pas de fabrication de
brosses à dents autres choses sont
méprisés aucune activité industrielle
mais nous sommes dans le domaine où se
façonnent l'opinion où la culture vous
en avait parlé de notre pays
vit
avec sa diversité et le domaine de
l'information qui est un domaine
fondamental pour l'exercice de la
démocratie pour que des citoyens
puissent exercer leur
qualité de citoyens c'est à dire être
informer informer des faits de ce qui se
passe pour pouvoir se faire eux mêmes
des opinions et donc c'est pour cela que
j'ai énuméré les activités qui façonnent
cette opinion qui interviennent dans le
domaine où la liberté et l'indépendance
sont fondamentaux pour un pays
démocratique alors vous pouvez minimiser
dire qu'il ya plus gros
quand même c'est la télé qui est très
prescriptrices encore d'opinion même
s'il ya les réseaux sociaux toutes les
études montrent que c'est très important
une chaîne d'information la radio avec
maintenant ce hachette et europe 1 il y
à paris match qui a un certain poids il
y a le jdd mais quand vous dites c'est
pour seulement un intérêt économique
beaucoup s'interrogent parce que bien
entendu
ce qui fait qu'on pas plus de vous
malgré le fait que vous êtes peut-être
plus petit que d'autres c'est que à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
prises on va dire dans les médias de
votre part il y a une certaine brutalité
a
liquidé détruire des rédactions
ça a été imité les pour faire ses news
ça a été europe 1 et on peut pas dire
que vous avez fait la chasse aux
gauchistes patrick cohen et d'autres où
son parti et puis aujourd'hui paris
match le jdd même les rédactions sont
fut fondé communiqué
s'interrogent avec ensuite
une ligne donnée
qui idéologiquement très marqué par ce
que depuis la libération c'était des
idéologies qui était plutôt mio au ban
de la république c'est à dire qu'on ne
parlait pas impunément avec des propos
racistes sexistes homophobes et j'en
passe
sur des antennes qui sont pas des
antennes d'opinion puisque la convention
par exemple de ces news avec le csa
dit les choses et qu'il via une presse
écrite d'opinion mais les conventions de
ce qui est du domaine public
l'autorisation d'émettre par tradition
était pour des chaînes qui assurait
s'engager au pluralisme et c est donc
oui je ma question maintenant est et
est ce que l'intérêt seulement
économique vous n'avez aucune
volonté idéologique et est-ce que vous
n'êtes jamais parce que c'est ça aussi
la garantie qu'il ya des investissements
c'est bien de l'argent on peut produire
on peut créer mais vous n'intervenez pas
pour imprimer cette marque
dans les rédactions vous n'exercez pas
aussi à travers cette puissance
médiatique
l'intérêt économique
que vous avez par ailleurs ça n'a jamais
été mis au service de vos activités
économiques que j'ai citées par ailleurs
sur la question de l'intervention comme
vous savez monsieur le rapporteur
puisque vous m'avez posé déjà la
question il ya cinq ans sont les deux ou
trois même histoire qui se répète
indéfiniment le crédit mutuel et autres
histoires de la même nature pour
lesquels d'ailleurs maxime saada le
président de canal avait répondu il ya
cinq ans
filmé et dont vous pouvez repasser en
allant sur le net ce qu'il avait dit à
l'époque et j'ai vu que dans votre
commission vous aviez reçu récemment le
patron des antennes de ses new skies a
expliqué qu'il n'avait jamais eu
d'intervention de personnes est en tout
cas pas de moi
et qui ne m'avait jamais rencontré vu
une fois mais jamais parlé avec moi
vous savez très bien en tout cas je vous
le répète ce que je vous avais dit à
cinq ans en fait seul hiatus sur les
questions d'interventionnisme on répète
uniquement deux histoires ou trois
histoires qui sont toujours les mêmes
depuis cinq ans et qui sont d'ailleurs
assez ancien
c'est parce que à l'époque canal était
en grande difficulté canal france
perdait 4 à 500 millions d'euros par an
et vive 1,10 à l'époque était contrôlé
essentiellement par des fonds américains
qu'ils n'avaient aucune envie et aucun
intérêt à continuer à mettre de l'argent
de leur poche pour renflouer canal
france et à l'époque il fallait
malheureusement allé faire des économies
canal a vécu très bien quand il était en
monopole et malheureusement quand des
grands gafa sont arrivés quand des
grands groupes de sport sont arrivés
canal s'est retrouvé plus en difficulté
moi ma famille joue les 10 a été très
riche et puis un moment et s'est
retrouvé en difficulté
il a fallu faire des économies et il a
fallu faire des économies chez canal et
celui qui est allé qui a été envoyée
c'est moi ce qui était mon rôle se pense
et c'est naturel je voulais dit à
l'époque que j'ai été le bouc émissaire
parce que quand vous voulez faire des
économies aux gens qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire ils n'ont pas dire c'est affreux on
fait des économies 10 d'affreux il
intervient dans les contenus sans en
apporter aucun élément d'ailleurs et je
m'amusais en voyant le festival de
cannes pierre lescure lui même a dit il
ya quelques jours la canal avant c'était
500 personnes pendant quinze jours à
cannes dont canal vraiment ne peut plus
500 personnes de canal à cannes c'était
vrai 2000 euros par jour 500 personnes 1
million un million x 15 égale 15
millions et il fallait remonter comme ça
400 millions et donc voilà pourquoi
est-ce que tout ceci est venu à quel
moment tout ceci est venu pourquoi tout
ceci est venu c'est parce qu'en effet on
a été obligé de faire des économies
l'histoire d'i télé dont vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure i télé a englouti 400
millions d'euros au cours de son
existence 400 millions d'euros au cours
de son existence
il fallait à un moment mettre fin à ceux
ci là où je ne partage pas du tout ce
que vous dites c'est quand vous dites
nous avons détruit non nous avons
construit quand je suis arrivé chez
canal d'ailleurs j'ai dit je ne suis pas
là la cause de vos problèmes je suis là
conséquences de vos problèmes et
peut-être la solution
et quand on regarde tout ça au fond
qu'est ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que les 8000 personnes de canal
continue à travailler c'est que si vous
regardez ce que c'est que les chiffres
de viven dié de canal vous le verrez
dans les slides c'est 300 millions
d'obligations cinéma audiovisuel
chaque année 500 millions investis dans
le cinéma français et européen chaque
année 75 millions de redevances aux
sociétés d'auteurs chaque année c'est le
slide 12 2 milliards et demi d'impôts
payés entre 17 et 21 donc si vous voulez
je pense que d'être le bouc émissaire je
vous avais dit pas à l'époque bouc
émissaire vous avez dit paratonnerre
pourrait tout à fait exact veulent
l'assument volontiers c'est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est de savoir est ce que
canal a réussi à se sortir de toutes ces
questions oui est ce qu'il a réussi à
s'internationaliser parce que le
problème c'est pas seulement d'avoir la
culture française avoir la culture
européenne c'est de savoir est ce qu'on
est capable de l'internationaliser et la
force du groupe vivendi canal à la
différence de ses collègues français
c'est que c'est le seul groupe qui
vraiment développer à l'international
quand vous regardez d'ailleurs les
chiffres de canal et ou de vie 20 10
dans les différents métiers l'essentiel
est fait en permettant de rayonner aux
artistes extérieurs je reviendrai
maintenant sur un des points des
questions que vous avez soulevés qui
concerne en effet ce ne sont pas des
brosses à dents c'est ça m'a pas échappé
que ce sont pas des brosses à dents ou
des automobiles les créateurs de
contenus sont des gens
extraordinairement sensible par nature
c'est vrai pour légende havas c'est vrai
pour les gens de la télévision c'est
canal et c'est vrai pour l'édition ma
mère a été pendant 50 ans lectrice chez
gallimard donc est rapportée à la maison
les livres qu'elle est enfin plutôt les
manuscrits qu'elle lisait et j'ai
rencontré j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer d'état d'auteur de toutes
sortes dont je sais très bien ce que
sont les journalistes les créatifs etc
nous n'avons pas détruit nous avons
reconstruit et nous avons aujourd'hui
120 je crois ou 130 journalistes carte
de presse a dit thomas boddaert veut
croire chez ces news donc
de fait faire des économies est en effet
un moment pénible j'espère que ça ne
vous est pas arrivé moi ça m'est arrivé
je peux vous dire que c'est un
changement quand tout d'un coup on vous
annonce que ce qui faisait votre
monopôle ou ce qui faisait votre
richesse vous ne l'avez plus mais vous
avez deux solutions en face de ça la
première c'est de se laisser aller et
puis de faire faillite et puis la
deuxième c'est de reprendre de choisir
des gens de pousser à travailler
ensemble
d'essayer de rayonner à l'international
parce que c'est là vous frotter aux
concurrents réels et puis c'est de
donner les moyens d'avancer sur le long
terme et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
vous remercie de l'avoir reconnu tout à
l'heure notre groupe a réussi à se
redresser mais je re continue à vous
dire que c'est un groupe encore petit il
n'en reste pas moins que il n'ya aucune
idéologie politique vous avez parlé de
la libération d'abord dans mon adn la
seule chose qu'on peut dire en dehors du
fait que j'ai toujours dit que j'étais
démocrate chrétien c'est la liberté
voilà ma famille s'est battue
vous parliez de l'après guerre
mon père était dans la résistance d'hier
ils étaient de la classe 22e alors se
soustraire au st lô à l'époque c'était
un peu obligatoire
le 6 juin 44 au débarquement ils nient
avec 177 français général de gaulle a
été prévu prévenu la veille il a dit je
veux absolument que ce soit des français
gentile a dit écoutez je crois pas
qu'ils aient des françaises le pas sur
il ya 350 mille personnes qui débarquent
il y en a avec 177 sous les ordres de
lord lovât dont deux de ma famille ma
grand mère était au service action
pendant des dizaines d'années en
particulier pendant la guerre et j'ai un
autre oncle dans normandie niemen dont
je crois pas que j'ai un adn qui ne
permettent pas dire que je n'aime pas
passionnément mon pays ou que je n'aime
pas passionnément la démocratie j'aime
les deux mais je crois que c'est un peu
court d'aller ressortir des histoires
pour lesquels d'ailleurs on vous a
répondu
les personnes adéquates vous ont répondu
et je crois que vous réentendez maxime
saada bientôt et vous avez entendu
thomas boddaert il ya quelques temps
j'ai même vu dans vos auditions à
monsieur que je ne connais pas très
gentil visiblement monsieur vire qui a
dit mais monsieur bolloré n'est jamais
intervenu donc je crois qu'il faut
garder les choses telles qu'elles sont
en réalité ils vendent y est un groupe
qui est capable peut-être ce type
peut-être qu'à moi ce sera plus moi
puisque moi comme vous savez mon délai
de péremption arrivent à échéance et
quand nous allons fêter le bicentenaire
du groupe le 17 février prochain les
équipes dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
prennent la suite mais la question c'est
de savoir est ce que ce groupe est
capable d'aller faire rayonner la
culture française et européenne dans le
monde ou pas et moi je crois que le
rayonnement
l'aide aux créateurs le soutien aux
journalistes le soutien au dirigeant
c'est compatible avec la réussite
économique et je crois que l'un vers ce
n'est pas compatible alors je vais je
vais être prêt si vous vous l'aurez
justement parce que c'est ça c'est
intéressant qu'il y ait une suite ont
effectivement vous êtes déjà venu devant
le sénat à l'époque j'avais relayer
la sphère d'un documentaire qui vous
avait déplu de tristan valek qui depuis
d'ailleurs a été couronnée par le
célèbre prix
vers londres
un documentaire qui s'appelait vincent
bolloré un ami qui vous veut du bien et
qui mettait en accusation des activités
que vous aviez en afrique à travers
notamment cette histoire de d'enfants
qui travaillent sur les plantations et
vous avait réfuté d'ailleurs vous
m'aviez dit je vais attaquer en justice
parce que c'est faux
vous avez
attaqué en justice vous avez même
demandé 50 millions c'est pas rien
et ça fait peur en tous les cas j'ai vu
que les jugements et le jugement en
appel
vous on
retourne et disons-le affaire puisque
vous êtes
vous dit que vous avez
dégénérer en abus de droit d'ester en
justice et que le montant demandé est
exorbitant et vous avez vous été
condamnée à dix mille euros à verser au
groupe de télévision france télévisions
qui avait diffusé ce documentaire vous
confirmez
je confirme que nous n'avons jamais eu
ni moi ni aucun cadre ni aucun employé
du groupe bolloré dans les plantations
en afrique
ces panneaux de la même façon qu'il ya
des cambodgiens qui viennent faire un
procès en disant à la compagnie du
cambodge vous occuper nos terres il n'y
a pas de terrain dans la compagnie du
cambodge donc pardonnez moi de vous dire
le procès a relaxé de façon générale
parce qu'ils étaient entre guillemets de
bonne foi mais ça n'empêche pas que ces
plantations ne nous ont jamais appartenu
et que le jeune homme qui soi-disant
avait 14 ans et qui avait trois ou
quatre ans de plus c'est pas ça mais non
mais n'a jamais travaillé pour moi moi
je veux bien est accusé des choses mais
j'ai commise et 0 soit je ne suis pas
parfait mais j'assume et je ne me dérobe
pas oui mais là il s'agit en effet à
nouveau d'un sujet d' amalgame c'est à
dire qu'on dit vous gérez déporté sur
non nous ne gérons pas des plantations
il ya un groupe belge qui s'appelle
fabrice qui est majoritaire dans ses
plantations plus 90 nous en avons hérité
d'une participation quand nous avons
fusionné avec le crip rivaux et nous
n'avons jamais opérée dans ses
plantations je vous dis les choses
telles qu'elles sont je ne me dérobe pas
bien donc ici on n'est pas dans un
tribunal mois j'évoque des choses et je
me souviens vous avez dit que vous êtes
en justice pour m'avait demandé d'ouvrir
à la justice que vous venez de me dire
la justice a répondu que c'était une
procédure abusive et vous a condamné
vous pour procédure abusive
pas parce que effectivement
il y à un des sujets de la pression sur
l'information ce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle les procédures bâillon on
demande des hommes si exorbitantes que
ça fait que des producteurs souvent ne
veulent pas prendre le risque d'
enquêter ou d'aller trop en avant sur un
salon de choses parce que ils pourraient
se retrouver sur la paille s'il était
condamné donc vous avez fait trois
procédures de ce type que vous avez
perdu en justice et on vous reproche
souvent sur vos activités effectivement
d'empêcher une certaine liberté
d'enquêter et de faire des reportages je
veux finir avec ma dernière question
parce que là franchement
vous n'avez pas répondu du tout sur la
connotation
politique et idéologique certains vont
plus loin j'ai lu beaucoup et deux
hommes y compris un ancien président de
la république qui a qui dit que vous
vous avez fabriqué un candidat à la
présidentielle quand il a été
renvoyé
2012 je crois d'itélé vous avez dit ont
piqué une colère noire et il est revenu
assez fortement sur le paysage
personne ne croit que vous n'y êtes pour
rien dans sa présence dans votre volonté
qu'ils puissent avoir pignon sur rue sur
l'antenne de ses news et personne ne
pense qu'il n'y a aucune connotation
idéologique aux politiques aux médias
que vous prenez que vous saisissez et
qu'il n'y a pas de changement assez
important de la ligne éditoriale et des
rédactions dans ces médias quand vous en
prenez le contrôle donc vous vous
définissez comme démocrate chrétien est
ce que le
racisme le négationnisme sont des
valeurs démocrates chrétiennes je ne
crois pas et je voulais vous demander si
c'est à votre insu qu'une telle ligne
éditoriale s'impose dans les médias que
vous contrôlez y compris les sommes que
vous mettez c'est quand même vous qui
les mettait à la place où les femmes
leur passé et leur revendications
idéologiques politiques sont marqués
nettement souvent à l'extrême droite
vous n'y êtes pour rien à écouter je
pense que vous prenez des petits bouts
de choses vous les mettez ensemble pour
essayer de faire une histoire on
pourrait par exemple dire que je suis
déconstructionniste ok vous avez vu la
polémique sur yale yale c'est
le petit robert le petit robert c'est
editis
editis et vincent bolloré dont vincent
bolloré est déconstructionniste voilà
vous avez des dizaines de milliers
d'heures sur nos programmes voilà et
quant à zemmour pardonnez moi mais il
publier des livres à des centaines de
milliers d'exemplaires bien avant qu'il
ne revienne sur ses news je vous
rappelle qu'il est sur le figaro je vous
rappelle qu'il est sur l'a6 et comme par
hasard c'est quand il est sur ces news
récemment problème mais je redis il ya
tellement de courant de pensée dans nos
livres dans nos émissions
la personne ne pensait personne ne
savait qu'ils allaient de président de
la république franchement c'est pas
raisonnable
et sera partagé moi je voudrais quand
même un peu éclairé au delà de la
question la personne en question le rôle
de l'actionnaire par rapport à aux
médias c'est un point qui nous concerne
sur cette commission denquête solesmes
la concentration vous aviez dit en 2016
angers re ecoutez-la l'audition où vous
aviez lu ici même au sénat pour définir
justement ce le rôle qui était le vôtre
en tant qu'actionnaire principal et vous
aviez dit précisément
vous avez repris un peu les mêmes termes
dans votre propos liminaire le rôle de
l'actionnaire il consiste à fixer un cap
a nommé des équipes a parlé avec elle
pour s'assurer qu'elles soient suivies
qu'elles suivent toujours ce cap et à
répondre à leurs questions je sais les
termes précis que vous aviez utilisé à
l'époque jusqu'où ça va la définition de
ce cap quand il s'agit d'un média est ce
que ça va jusqu'à définir la ligne
éditoriale et de recrutement des équipes
quand il s'agit aussi d'un média
jusqu'où ça va s que ça va jusqu'au
choix des éditorialistes des principaux
journalistes
évidemment ce sont les dirigeants que je
choisis mes depuis 40 ans le succès de
ce groupe a été de faire des repérages
de talent alors évidemment maintenant on
dit zemmour mais on pourrait dire yves
calvi j'ai passé du temps avec il
cavaliere calvi qui est venu d'ailleurs
sur le groupe canal j'ai passé du temps
avec bono le chanteur qui est venu c'est
universel j'ai passé du temps avec marc
levy je passe du temps avec bernard
henri lévy mon travail consiste en effet
hafid enfin consistait puisque
maintenant je ne suis plus que conseil
et bientôt plus rien mais mon travail
consistait pour l'essentiel à fixer des
caps à choisir des gens et à les laisser
travailler et vous connaissez se croient
les dirigeants du groupe vivendi canal
sont des gens qui ont des personnalités
de l'autorité des compétences ils sont
d'ailleurs pénalement responsable de ce
qui se passe dans leurs médias donc je
ne vois pas comment on pourrait leur
imposer quoi que ce soit et j'observe
que dans toutes les commissions vous
avez tenu jusqu'à présent toutes les
personnes que vous avez interrogé aucune
n'a dit que j'étais intervenu
personnellement sur quoi que ce soit et
je vous redis le groupe est tellement
vaste on peut dire une chose et son
contraire sur mes avis politique si on
commence à disséquer je vous ai donné
l'exemple duels mais je pourrais vous
donner des tapes d'autres exemples de
gens qui est très raide yves est dite ou
parle sur nos antennes et je ne peux en
aucune façon est responsable de ça et je
trouve au contraire et on vous l'a dit
toutes les expressions sont sur les
différentes antennes mais enfin en
réalité on fait un monde si on veut bien
repasser le slide qui montre ce que nous
sommes en termes de
d'audience sur le plan des
des émissions d'information qui est
absolument risible c'est tout petit
petit parce qu'en vérité sur canal les
vrais sujets c'est le sport
pardonnez moi je ne retrouve pas je vais
finir par le retrouver quelques pas
voilà
je ne sais qu'une leucate voilà non ça
c'est europe il y en avait un autre
juste avant peut-être sur le segment de
l'information voilà après 4
l'a4 dont il y en avait encore un plus
petit en tête voilà c'est ça segment de
l'information tv vous voyez on est à 1
par rapport à 9 à 7 à 4 donc on est tout
petit en réalité et donc l'essentiel de
canal qu'est ce que c'est c'est le
cinéma c'est le sport et c'est les
séries oui vous avez ça la vérité vous
avez tout à fait raison nous rappeler
les parts d'audience à dire j'ai pris
soin aussi dans mon com vous propose
introductif de les rappeler néanmoins il
ya quand même un sujet sur sur ces news
et sur la télévision en général c'est
que jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas de télé
d'opinion
la télévision française était
contrairement à la presse qui est basé
sur une presse d'opinion historiquement
elle a été faite comme ça là de la
télévision notamment parce que les les
droits des maîtres sont en nombre limité
n'a pas été construite sur un schéma de
télé d'opinion
certain nombre d'observateurs des médias
constate que la chaîne ses news je crois
que
nombreux à porter ce constat lé la
chaîne ces news n'est pas loin d'être
une télé d'opinion est ce que vous
partagez ce constat ecoutez-moi fait vue
l'audition de thomas boddaert qui en est
le patron qui dit que c'est une chaîne
de débat et vous aurez maxime saada qui
viendra je crois à plélo puis fontaine
qui est le président de vivendi ils
auraient dû prendre ma place ailleurs et
vous verrez que voilà personne n'a
l'ambition ou l'intention ou l'erreur
d'essayer de faire des chaînes d'opinion
c'est pas dans l'objectif du groupe
vivendi canal ça n'a pas d'importance ça
n'a pas d'intérêt nous sommes là pour
être
sur la liberté de l'expression et nous
sommes là pour l'essentiel pour
permettre à nos clients qui veulent voir
sur canal du sport du cinéma et des
séries de leur donner le mieux de ce
qu'on peut donner dans ce domaine
monsieur année dernière question de
nombre une remarque heures une remarque
monsieur zemmour lui même dans son livre
dit que c'est lui que c'est vous pardon
qui a l'avait convaincu de rejoindre la
chaîne il était déjà d'ailleurs condamné
pour des propos et encore hier d'autres
propos donc il dit lui dans son livre
que c'est vous qui l'avait convaincu de
venir comme je vous ai dit tu râles à
l'heure je rencontre beaucoup de gens
j'essaie de venir faire venir beaucoup
de gens et malheureusement pour moi ou
heureusement pour moi je ne sais pas
monsieur zemmour était très connu bien
avant qu'il ne me rends compte pour la
première fois
ils vendaient des centaines de milliers
de livres il est sur les autres chaînes
ça ne posait aucun problème est ce que
savait très bien c'est venu pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées tout à l'heure
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que eric
zemmour s'il n'est pas élu président la
république revienne sur ses news mais
attendez c'est pas moi mais pardonnez
moi je suis banquier de profession noble
retour je n'ai pas le pouvoir de nommer
qui que ce soit l'inter des chaînes
voilà je peux proposer je peux donner
mon avis je peux dire ne pensez vous pas
que voilà et si quelqu'un n'a pas envie
de le faire il le fait pas et j'ai
quatre cinq six sept
personnes qui sont toutes connues et
reconnues pour leurs forces que si elle
considère c'est pas bon pour le groupe
ne le ferons pas donc ma capacité
personnelle allait imposer des choses et
pas très importante contrairement à ce
que vous pensez j'aurais man u de nay
merci président bonjour monsieur bolloré
le président la faune commencer par cela
il disait que votre audition devant la
commission denquête était
particulièrement médiatique je n'aurais
pas faire de jeu de mots mais je crois
que nous battons des records d'audience
grâce à vous
et ce matin en lisant l'opinion je
voyais
concentration dans l'édition sous la
plume de catherine boulay bolloré sur le
gril des sénateurs donc juste dire et
tout à fait de façon personnelle que
nous sommes ici sachant le sérieux des
travaux du sénat et des commission
denquête sous la responsabilité de
laurent laffont sommes d'ici pour
d'abord comprendre analyser et cette
compréhension et cette analyse
nourrissent ensuite l'écriture d'une loi
pour l'adapter à la société actuelle
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
commencé votre carrière professionnelle
à l'âge de 18 ans en 1970 à l'union
européenne industrielle et financière
c'est exact c'est assez actuelle
et puis un demi-siècle s'en est suivie
d'une trajectoire exceptionnelle vous
l'avez dit d'une réussite familiale
qui inspire dans notre pays deux choses
où le respect et l'admiration
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on crée de
la richesse de l'emploi et du
sacro-saint pouvoir d'achat
ou alors du rejet de la suspicion parce
que dans notre beau pays la réussite des
plaies
alors moi ce que je ce que je voudrais
comprendre pour quelqu'un qui est assez
visionnaire qu'on vous apprécie ou pas
mais personne ne peut vous daignez ce
cette qualité d'être visionnaire puisque
vous l'avez dit vous avez commencé dans
les médias dans les années 2000 donc ça
fait déjà plus de 20 ans à votre avis et
ça sera ma question
comment peut-on concilier à notre époque
la nécessaire recomposition du marché
des médias
avec la non moins nécessaire
préservation du pluralisme qui fait
vivre notre démocratie
moi personnellement je trouve qu'il ya
un grand pluralisme aujourd'hui est que
si on veut aller écouter les uns ou les
autres on est capable de le retrouver le
vrai danger ce sont les gaffes à qui son
vous l'avez vu des poids considérable
qui passe à travers des tuyaux non
contrôlée non contrôlable
et moi je crois que la vraie question
est de savoir est ce que on est capable
tout en permettant à des médias de se
développer
de leur faire gagner de l'argent en
restant dans la pluralité moi je crois
que c'est possible
et c'est vrai que
vous avez un sujet compliqué parce que
la concentration des médias forcément
pose problème mais la taille des
concurrents que nous avons
pose aussi problème et vous avez en
effet un sujet complexe à régler nous
vous savez ça fait je les dis dans trois
semaines ça fera deux cents ans que le
groupe existe donc nous avons connu nous
aurons connu trois rois un empereur 26
président de la république donc on
s'adaptera
mais
c'est un sujet complexe parce que je
peux vous dire que de ma petite fenêtre
comment faire pour que vive indique
annales malgré les critiques et le reste
et je redis je fais le paratonnerre avec
plaisir c'est mon travail je sais pas
comment ils vont faire après mais enfin
bon je resterai peut-être quand même en
paratonnerre apparent
c'est compliqué parce que la taille est
énorme quand vous voyez arriver netflix
canal c'est pas parce qu'ils ont mal
travaillé qu'ils sont trouvés devant des
difficultés ils sont trouvés devant un
petit vendeur de tee loueur de cassettes
qui tout d'un coup est devenu un groupe
à 500 milliards aux 400 milliards de
capitalisation et qui finalement fait
des séries en payant le double la vraie
question c'est est-ce qu'à la fin une
fois qu'il aura les x millions de
clients française qui continuera à faire
ou pas la place pour la culture de notre
pays c'est ça la vraie question est
quand vous avez quand même des
entrepreneurs qui sont dans ce pays
il ya plus de chances qu'ils défendent
la culture de leur pays que quand c'est
les entrepreneurs de l'étranger et
j'allais même dire que dans tous les
secteurs industriels quand vous avez un
groupe français s'ils rencontrent des
difficultés il gardera ses usines en
france mais si c'est un groupe étranger
il fermera ses usines en france donc
vous avez une difficile mission
puisqu'il faut à la fois aider
des gens à se développer et éviter
qu'ils aient une concentration trop
forte je peux pas répondre à cette
question malheureusement merci donc aux
propos très aimable en tout cas merci
monsieur le président monsieur bolloré
tous les quinze jours tiens aussi à
remercier pour la clarté de vos réponses
permettez moi tout d'abord de revenir
sur les questions de david assouline
qu'est ce qui vous attire vers les
médias parce que vous l'avez dit c'est
la rentabilité j'ai bien compris dans
votre dans les propos mais enfin c'est
quand même un milieu où depuis que vous
êtes investi vous avez pris quand même
beaucoup de coups est ce qu'il n'a pas
fait des effets collatéraux sur les
autres activités de votre groupe ça
c'est ma peau marquez sur la deuxième
justement quand on a un groupe comme le
vôtre et y avoir certaines passerelle
quand vous êtes propriétaire de havas
qui
met en place des programmes
publicitaires qui conçoit certaines
publicités qui ensuite sont achetés par
des médias est-ce que là il n'y a pas
forcément on n'est pas tenté d'aller
toujours vers les médias qui
appartiennent au même groupe
et puis juste pour revenir aussi sur un
sujet abordé par david à celui d'honda
auditionné il ya quelques jours le
directeur général de reporters sans
frontières
qui nous a parlé à sa façon
de votre personne et je voulais savoir
dans les propos qu'on vous reproche il
ya une gestion assez brutale dans vos
affaires est ce que vous les assumez
merci monsieur bolloré merci beaucoup
n'ont écouté je pense pas qu'ils aient
de gestion brutale il ya simplement
le courage de dire les choses
et le courage quand elles sont graves
j'ai évoqué le cas de canal tout à
l'heure où de itélé de prendre des
mesures
quand vous êtes malade
vous avez des gens autour de vous qui
vous disent t'inquiète pas ça n'a aucune
importance continue et puis un moment
vous retrouvez avec une situation qui a
empiré ou alors vous avez
quelqu'un qui vous dit voilà tu as une
maladie faut la regarder va passer un
examen et on prendra les mesures pour la
réparer si c'est ça que vous appelez
brutale oui je suis brutale parce que
c'est brutal de dire la vérité c'était
brutal de dire à canal ça perd 400
millions mais vous savez les coûts
pardon je sais que vous êtes pris par le
temps mais si vous aviez deux minutes
j'ai mis
quelques minutes de film qui sont
passées pendant que j'étais président
chez canal
et actif à l'époque puisque après j'ai
laissé la présidence à un maxime saada
et à jean christophe thiery mais pendant
que j'étais actif il ya un petit film si
vous voulez bien le passé il y en a pour
deux minutes qui vous montrera ce qui se
passait chez canal pendant que j'y étais
et qui montrera que tout ça voilà ce que
je vous propose monsieur bolloré c'est
de le passer à la fin peut-être envie
les nombreuses questions à monsieur
régis laconi vidéo et quant aux coûts
c'est vrai qu'ils sont élevés c'est pour
ça que je dis que je fais paratonnerre
mais je pense qu'il ya une grande
satisfaction dans les équipes de savoir
que maintenant le groupe gagne de
l'argent de savoir que maintenant la
situation est rétablie on peut investir
à l'étranger
je crois que les gens de canal était
très très très inquiet à l'époque et je
pense qu'en effet c'est des coups c'est
pas bon pour le moral conçu arrivé
d'ailleurs à la tête de vivendi on m'a
dit mais surtout tu t'assois tu prends
la cave à cigares et tu fais rien du
tout est attend que ça passe et tu
profites
est-ce que c'est l'adn dont je parlais
tout à l'heure ma maîtresse quand
j'étais en septième un avait envoyé un
bulletin de consignes avec marc et à mes
parents vincent se mêle de tout il n'a
plus qu'à prendre ma place
je sais pas c'est peut-être comme ça
mais en tout cas si vous voulez c'est à
la fois pénible mais d'un autre côté le
plaisir du travail accompli la
satisfaction de voir les 80000 personnes
rien que cinéma français dont on parle
il ya cinq ans cinéma français
maintenant on a plus d'inquiétudes sur
canal alors après est ce que le cinéma
français préfèrent amazon et préfère
netflix à cesson soi mais en tout cas on
ne lui a pas retirer la carte cam et je
pense que c'est bien ce qui a été fait
par un lot de puyfontaine
chez vivendi par maxime saada et toutes
les équipes chez canal et sa récompense
des coûts prix je les trouve évidemment
souvent injuste mais bon
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
michel logis sur sur les liens entre les
entreprises notamment par rapport à
havas parce que je crois que ça
correspond quand même à un avis et une
remarque faite par l'autorité des
marchés financiers
dans son rapport 2010 9 le fait que
l'étanchéité entre les différents des
éléments de du groupe notamment
damas avec les éditeurs n'est pas
assurée et que du coup il peut y avoir
un distorsion par rapport à des
concurrents écoutez je ne crois pas
monsieur le président parce que havas ne
fait que prendre la publicité de ses
clients pour la mettre sur des médias
sylvain s'amuser à les mettre la
publicité
sur ses propres médias ça se verrait
très vite et il y aurait un problème
mais je rappelle simplement une chose
canal+ le groupe je veux pas dire de
bêtises je crois que ces quatre
milliards et demi de chiffre d'affaires
ou 5 milliards de chiffre 5 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires
sur les 5 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires la totalité de la publicité
sur canal c'est 100 millions c'est à
dire que ces 2 % donc même à 20
s'amuserait ce qui n'est évidemment pas
le cas parce qu'il ya des murailles de
chine ça n'aurait pas de conséquence ni
pour l'un ni pour l'autre
nick barcoo merci
monsieur bolloré voilà dans vos propos
introductif vous avez exprimé
l'intention de faire rayonner la culture
française face à la culture asiatique et
américaine ce sont des intentions très
louable voilà mais parallèlement il faut
comprendre l'inquiétude concernant vos
acquisitions dans le domaine des médias
et de l'édition je prends l'exemple du
slide numéro 6 avec le journal du
dimanche
ce lundi 14 janvier la rédaction du jdd
a exprimé ses craintes de devenir jeu si
un vulgaire médias d'opinion comme ses
news suite à la nomination comme
directeur général jérôme béglé
chroniqueur régulier de ses news la
rédaction du jdd très inquiète pour son
indépendance et prend en exemple ce qui
s'est passé à europe 1 avez-vous des
réponses à apporter à la rédaction du
jdd première question excusez moi j'ai
une deuxième très courte le candidat
eric zemmour annonce vouloir démanteler
le service public france télé et radio
france partagez vous ces propos c'est
bref
écouter sur zemmour à nouveau
franchement j'ai pas plus de
responsabilités de poids sur lui que
l'on à nicolas de tavernot le patron
propriétaire du figaro les dassault
monsieur edelstenne
j'ai vu qu'il me téléphonait tous les
jours qu'on déjeuner tous les mois que
j'ai déjeuné qu'une seule fois avec lui
qui est la fois en effet on lui a
proposé de rejoindre ses news mais là
aussi si on commence à dire attendez
c'est pas vrai on va dire qu'on fait des
procès bâillon si on commence à dire
donc voilà sur zemmour franchement eric
zemmour était un droit de s'exprimer il
fait ce qu'il veut et son programme ne
me regarde pas je n'ai jamais fait de
politique je ne ferai jamais de
politique en ce qui concerne le journal
du dimanche je n'ai aucune
responsabilité dans le journal du
dimanche je n'ai pas nommer personne et
c'est arnaud lagardère qui gère son
groupe
mais évidemment il ya une telle pression
qui est fait par les médias en faisant
vincent bolloré épouvantable le
boogeyman d'épouvantail que évidemment
je vais normal que le journal du
dimanche faisait peur même sans me
connaître je les connais pas mais avec
ce qu'on écrit c'est naturel qu'ils
aient peur
donc s'il avait envie de me voir mais je
n'ai aucun rôle pour les voir ils
verraient que je suis un garçon tout à
fait normal et qu'ils ont pas se sentir
menacé c'est un avis personnel et line
renaud garabédian et pardon juste
monsieur peillon et arnaud de
puyfontaine qui est le vrai président de
vivendi c'est le président du directeur
du lundi donc je suis très honorée
d'être la rue est un garçon qui connaît
par coeur la presse tous les gens de la
presse les cônes le connaissent et
savent que c'est un garçon tout à fait
remarquable donc si un jour il devait y
avoir je dis bien si un jour il devait y
avoir une autorisation de bruxelles est
un lien entre le groupe lagardère et le
groupe vivendi je suis sûr que tout ça
se passerait très bien comme ça se passe
très bien dans les autres magazines du
groupe j 20 10 mon avis pardon monsieur
le président je l'aurais est venue une
renault garabédian merci monsieur le
président monsieur bolloré nous avons
auditionné en début de semaine un
professeur d'université historien des
médias qui nous a indiqué que la
concentration n'était pas un problème
démocratique mais une question
économique
qu'il n'y avait pas de rapport entre
concentration et pluralisme et qu'au
contraire en 40 ans les supports de
diffusion avait énormément augmenté
s'étaient multipliées pourtant 16 % des
français seulement font confiance aux
journalistes
qu'en pensez vous
j'ai pas d'idée malheureusement madame
la sénatrice je ne suis pas du tout dans
compétents dans ces matières
je ne sais pas je pense que je vous dis
il est possible de se renseigner il est
possible de lire il est possible
d'écouter la télévision il est possible
de regarder sur le net des informations
tellement diverse
que les gens sont des idées voilà moi je
n'ai pas d'opinion à exprimer et
malheureusement je vous le disais tout à
l'heure votre commission c'est compliqué
parce que c'est pas comment régler ces
questions
je ne sais pas comment régler ces
questions nous en tout cas à nouveau
l'essentiel de la vie du groupe vivendi
canal à la télévision c'est le cinéma le
sport et les séries je redis pour
enlever le fantasme de du projet
politique
on a un truc insignifiant en termes de
d'outils d'information d'outil de
propagande si on voulait faire de la
propagande c'est infinitésimal
si on avait vraiment eu un projet
politique c'est sans doute pas
d'ailleurs canal dans lequel on serait
allé ou en tout cas pas comme ça on
serait allés plutôt sur l'a6 ou sur des
des opérations beaucoup plus ouverte
nous nous sommes spécialisés
dans ses contenus et en plus ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'international je
voulais dit tout à l'heure
l'essentiel de canal aujourd'hui son
développement se fait à l'international
on a plus de 20 millions d'abonnés dont
plus de la moitié maintenant sont à
l'international et si vous me re
convoquer dans cinq ans vous avez aucune
chance parce que je serai gâteux
vous verrez qu'il y aura 30 millions
d'abonnés sur canal et y en aura 20
millions à l'international
donc le sujet politique n'est pas à
l'intérieur de canal un sujet essentiel
je suis lien bargeton qui est derrière
son écran
je n'y avais rejetons
nous le voyons julien oui
si vous m'entendez oui très bien entendu
oui bonsoir
bonsoir vincent bolloré julien bargeton
sénateur de paris montsouris cher
vincent ont soit alors j'ai une question
qui prolonge eu celle qui a été posée
notamment par michel laugier et puis
également le le président sur le lien
avec havas quand même puisque vous nous
avez dit qu' il n'y avait pas de lien
mais lorsque vous avez pris la tête de
vivendi lors de l'assemblée générale du
24 juin 2014 vous avez affiché votre
volonté de transformer cette holding
financière en groupe industriel intégré
dans les contenus il semblerait que
lorsque havas media que vous contrôlez
recommande un annonceur de choisir un
média pour diffuser ses publicités les
chaînes du groupe canal+ que vous
contrôlez également soit favorisée en
2018 je reconnais ce sont des chiffres à
peu anciens ont peut-être que vous allez
me répondre
ces chaînes ont par exemple représenté
12 1% des espaces publicitaires achetés
par havas alors qu'elles n'ont pesé que
9% chez les autres agences concurrentes
il ya donc une discordance 23.1 aussi
pouvez vous nous dire si des consignes
ont déjà été données chez havas media
pour favoriser les chaînes du groupe
canal+ sinon comment expliquer cette
différence par rapport aux autres
agences et ont-elles été corrigé depuis
2018 deuxième question c'est news a reçu
le 3 décembre une mise en demeure du csa
relatives à l' équilibre des opinions
notamment avec la diffusion à vue j'ai
nocturne pour les temps de parole de
l'exécutif ainsi que ceux de l efi et
donc le csa a réagi le 3 décembre par
une mise en demeure pouvez-vous nous
garantir que les mesures ont été prises
pour mettre fin à ces pratiques et que
désormais le rééquilibrage a été opéré
alors merci merci monsieur le sénateur
alors sur la deuxième question j'ai
aucun pouvoir pour dire à quiconque de
rééquilibrer mais j'ai entendu thomas
boddaert qui a expliqué que ce n'était
qu'une mise en demeure préventive et que
depuis les équilibres avait été maintenu
d'ailleurs sur une règle du jeu qu'il ne
connaissait pas qui était le distinguo
entre le jour et la nuit mais enfin ils
se sont remis en ordre et à ma
connaissance je vois pas de raison
pourquoi ces dirigeants qui risqueraient
des sanctions et donc leur place
risquerait de faire des choses qui sont
pas conforme à la légalité sur havas je
n'en suis plus président depuis beaucoup
d'années et vous pouvez en recevoir les
dirigeants mais c'est un vieux débat sur
les 12 9% 6% il ya ceux qui disent que
publicis comme c'est notre concurrent
fait exprès de pas donner à canal
et que havas donne un peu plus voilà
mais je redis sur canal 5 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires et donc les 3% de
plus de havas s'est peut-être un million
ou deux donc si vous voulez pardonnez
moi je crois qu'aucune consigne
anormale ne puisse être donnée pour des
sommes aussi risible donc je ne le crois
pas du tout mais interrogé les gens
d'arras si vous le souhaitez vous verrez
qu'il ya des murailles de chine et que
tous les grands groupes de publicité
dans le monde nous ne sommes que cinq ou
six dans le monde il n'y en a cinq ou
six dans le monde font bien attention
parce que sinon ils perdraient leurs
clients et qu' ils le donnent de la
publicité que dans les endroits où il ya
évidemment des tarifs favorables et un
intérêt pour leurs clients
là où par contre s'il motorisée de
compléter la question
on est en effet un groupe industriel
intégré mais avec havas était pas dans
ce cadre là c'était dans le cadre de la
création en fait les films duré trois
heures du temps du docteur jivago puis
ensuite une heure et demie à deux heures
et puis ensuite on est passé à des
séries de 20 minutes et beaucoup de gens
pensent que l'accélération des contenus
et l'intérêt des gens pour voir des
contenus de plus en plus rapidement va
faire que la durée des films qui sont
gardés peut se réduire
or qui sont les gens qui font les films
les plus courts et les plus efficaces
sont les publicitaires et ça c'est un
sujet pour le futur vous avez d'ailleurs
les podcasts qui sont des petits
éléments qui sont un peu plus court et
c'était dans cet esprit là que j'avais
dit il faudrait regarder si on peut
faire travailler les créatifs davasse
dans le monde parce que vous rappelle
qu'avant là où je pense que la france
n'est que 20% et que l'étranger 80 %
est-ce qu'on peut les faire travailler
ces gens qui ont 25 ans 30 ans 32 ans
avec des créateurs de séries pour voir
si on peut faire des formats c'était une
des idées à l'époque qui avaient été mis
en oeuvre et c'est pour ça que vous en
avait parlé à l'époque
sylvie robert
oui merci monsieur président lors
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
donc je vais essayer d'aller un peu plus
loin dans la réflexion là qu'est posée
cet après midi
vous nous avez dit monsieur bolloré donc
c'est une question purement économique
parce que c'est le deuxième secteur des
médias le deuxième secteur le plus
rentable du monde que vous êtes encore
tout petit
vous avez dit également la concentration
des médias posent problème mais ce qui
pose problème c'est la taille de nos
concurrents
quand j'entends le encore ça veut dire
que vous considérez qu'il faut
concentrer encore plus pour affronter la
taille de ses concurrents qui pose
problème
donc quelle est votre stratégie à venir
même si on sait très bien et que vous
n'êtes que conseiller que vous allez
passer la main mais ce qu'on voudrait
comprendre
c'est que et mes collègues l'ont dit
indirectement on parle de concentration
verticale
verticale d'abord j'aimerais savoir si
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qualificatif
concentration horizontale ou verticale
qui permet finalement de pouvoir
avoir un système intégré je crois que
c'est julien bargeton chi chi chi le
disais donc est ce que le encore fait
que vous avez une stratégie pour aller
plus loin est ce que vous considérez que
dans le paysage actuel face à ses
concurrents qui pose problème
on est en capacité de concentrer encore
plus sachant que vous avez compris si
cette commission denquête a été créé
c'est bien parce que la question du
pluralisme de la démocratie de la loi de
86 qui est au coeur de nos débats de la
question forcément de la liberté des
rédactions de l'heure de leur capacité à
pouvoir travailler
librement
est un sujet alors vous réponse on les
comprend mais lien il ya un sujet donc
moi j'aimerais que vraiment vous alliez
plus loin pour nous dire et puis c'est
ma deuxième question elle est un peu
c'est quoi pour vous l'information
aujourd'hui dans une démocratie vivante
vivaces qui n'est pas
alors en termes de qualité je termine
dans le débat public ce qu'on peut voir
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
et enfin je terminerais qui aussi
revient et c est vous l'avez c'est que
des journalistes partent et ça n'est pas
rien quand on apprend que 2 itélé à
seignosse dit après 70 journalistes qui
sont partis alors vous allez me dire ils
ont toute la liberté de partir et ils
sont partis pour différentes raisons
mais ce sont là aussi des faits vous
parliez de fait et non pas de propos qui
interroge qui questionne et c'est pour
ça que dans le débat public et et qu'on
est là aussi pour essayer de comprendre
donc voilà mes questions sont simples
parce que derrière il ya la question de
la démocratie et de la formation dans
notre pays qu'est la france et vous avez
commencé par des ajouts sans merci que
vous êtes attaché vous êtes breton et
moi aussi à la culture française et
romain
d'abord madame la sénatrice les
journalistes sont partis mais les
journées ils sont revenus sont pas les
mêmes mais c'est comme la mer en
bretagne chez nous et ses cartes et puis
revient voilà donc le groupe pardon le
groupe canal voilà pardon oui c'est la
mer et donc vous avez des gens qui
effrayées s'en vont et puis vous avez
des gens contents qu'ils viennent et
c'est comme ça dans la vie c'est comme
ça dans les partis politiques c'est
comme ça la chambre c'est comme ça dans
les vies personnelles voilà c'est comme
ça il ya des gens qui partent
peut-être pour des bonnes raisons
peut-être pour me des mauvaises raisons
ils sont d'ailleurs protégés ils ont des
clauses de conscience est très bien
c'est fait pour ça mais y en a qui
reviennent voilà on n'a pas détruit des
rédactions
ils restent un champ de ruines on a
reconstruit avec des gens qui avaient
envie de construire avec nous alors pour
différentes raisons ils peuvent trouver
que les équipes que j'ai mises en place
sont des gens avec qui il faut pas
travailler mais c'est leur droit
mais je ne peux pas dire
on a fait partir des gens point non on a
fait partir des gens et les gens en
nombre supérieur sont revenus donc si
vous voulez en termes de construction
c'est la vie et je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose sur vos questions
précédentes sont des sujets importants
alors d'abord sur la concentration dit
horizontale c'est à dire dans le même
secteur je vais vous donner un exemple
très parlant il ya une très grosse
affaire aux etats-unis dans l'édition
qui était à vendre qui s'appelle simon
and schuster
et
achète était trop petit pour l'acheter
editis était trop petit pour l'acheter
et ensemble ils auraient pu l'acheter
laisser bertelsmann qui la hd
donc on voit bien que le poids et je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure quand on
a regardé la taille même si hachette
editis se mariait
et ça n'arrivera pas s'enquit évidemment
des mesures qui soient prises en france
parce que les tailles sont très
importantes mais même s'ils se mariaient
on ne serait encore que les troisièmes
est loin d y ait derrière en terme de
profitabilité de valeur des 1er mai sur
la concentration verticale c'est sans
doute encore plus intéressant parce que
regarder le groupe disney
c'est une concentration parfaitement
verticale personne ne va dire à
eurodisney attendait mais on va pas
mettre blanche neige c'est insupportable
ça fait partie de votre groupe personne
ne dit on va interdire à peter pan
d'aller à eurodisney parce que ça fait
partie de la stratégie de disney la
stratégie tous ces groupes c'est de
faire ce qu'ils appellent du 360° ce qui
veut dire en gros on fait un peu de tout
dans tous les sens et il trouve un
personnage
nickel a souri ils font un journal ils
font des dessins animés ils font des
des clubs on peut aller des villages on
peut aller voir les centres de loisirs
et puis à un moment
les personnages sont un peu désuet donc
on fait des films avec des acteurs plus
épicée et on reprend blanche neige qui
devient je sais plus quel et l'actrice
qui joue dedans angelina jolie je crois
ou charlize theron opérons je ne sais
plus et puis etc etc et puis un moment
se fait à faire des marvel et apprendre
des super héros et puis à la fin tout ça
marche ensemble et c'est ce fameux soft
power américains
et les asiatiques font pareil alors je
ne voudrais pas vous donner une
impression qu'on va aller faire une
grande machine avec des choses qui
tourne dans tous les sens c'est pas du
tout comme ça que ça se passe pour que
des créatifs reste avec vous il faut
qu'il soit apprécié pour qu'un auteur
puisse écrire son livre être heureux
restez chez vous il faut que vous
puissiez lui donner un cadre qui soit un
cadre personnel donc ce ne sont pas des
grandes machines se sont au contraire
sur mesure des alliances qui sont faites
mais regardez un garçon peut-être tout à
l'heure on passera le film c'est alex
lutz voilà alex lutz est un garçon qui
j'ai commencé comme speakerine entre
guillemets dans des séries de petits
trucs de canal et qui est maintenant un
des plus grands acteurs connus à
l'international quand on regarde angèle
la chanteuse les maintenant dans le
monde entier etc etc donc moi je pense
que wie 20 10 mes successeurs s'ils en
ont le goût et la possibilité
ils ont une chance énorme de pouvoir
prendre ces français peu ou pas connus
et de les projeter dans le monde entier
parce que quand on parle de l'émission
là aussi à part quelques auteurs qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent la plupart des
gens dans l'édition crève la faim les
auteurs avec leurs droits d'auteur je
vous assure qu'ils s'en sortent pas et
donc un groupe qui est capable d'aller
prendre
un auteur français lui proposé de
traduire de vendre à l'étranger de faire
des séries ou des plus petits
élément digitaux et de les passer sur
dailymotion canal ou au dessus vous
assure moi je pense que c'est un projet
passionnant pour ce fameux soft power
qui est quand même très important pour
la france
bien derrière
monsieur bolloré merci vous savez quand
on réfléchit sur les conséquences
finalement de la concentration des
médias et donc moi j'aimerais un peu vos
vos conseils puisque vous dites que
maintenant c'est votre fonction et en
profiter avant que vous soyez gâteux
comme vous avez dit je pense ça nous
laisse quand même un petit peu de temps
malgré tout
quand vous dites que la motivation c'est
finalement la rentabilité économique
normal d'une entreprise et qu'on a
besoin d'eux de concentration on voit
fasse ça quel mastodondes on a à faire
face est ce qu'un jour pour être
conséquent même que la culture française
que la francophonie c'est un pass qui
est majoritaire dans le monde est-ce
qu'on ne risque pas un jour de délai
c'est justement la culture française
pour un problème de rentabilité
et est-ce qu'au contraire c'est pas
parce les petites les plus petites
sociétés celles qui ont que comme
finalement de zone de chalandise que que
le que nos les gens d'autres cultures et
bien sont pas ceux qui permettent de la
de la faire vivre et ce qui n'a pas donc
un risque dans cette concentration qu'on
souhaite pour résister aux gars femmes
mais qui va être quand même difficile
d'être obligé de rentrer dans une
culture insipide
international et de perdre un petit peu
notre
notre propre culture
française est-ce qu'il faut que la la
puissance publique justement soit très
contraignantes pour maintenir à la fois
je parte pas seulement même la pluralité
des opinions dans les médias mais même
pour imposer
culture française et là on serait quand
même dans un
dans un système qui serait un peu
coercitif et qui laisserait moins de
liberté donc on est vraiment un moment
des interrogations sur qu'est-ce qui
peut préserver la créativité de la
culture française sans trop la protéger
pour prendre et la priver
de liberté et créativité et en même
temps par la laisser au contraire
disparaître se diluer dans une culture
internationale pour des raisons de
rendement économique moi je crois
monsieur le sénateur que
mes successeurs yannick bolloré arnault
plus fun maxime saada sont convaincus
que nous avons un trésor le trésor c'est
notre histoire
alors pardon je vais pas le droit de
dire clovis charlemagne c'est très mal
vu aujourd'hui mais enfin quand même bon
on a des sites on a des lieux on a des
endroits magnifiques qu'on peut filmer
et moi je pense que c'est ce trésor qui
peut être mis en avant et qui peut être
exporté quand on fait vers ça et quand
on fait clovis voilà c'est plus
intéressant quand on fait superman 2 3 4
5 6 7 etc etc c'est passionnant c'est
formidable mais peut-être que de temps
en temps on peut aller vers quelque
chose d'un peu plus subtil un peu plus
raffiné et nos aïeux nous ont laissé ça
et moi je pense que si vous favorisez
des groupes français ou en tout cas vous
ne les empêchait pas de vivre et vous me
favorisée par des étrangers qui eux ont
une arrière-pensée complètement
différente de ce qui les intéresse
pardon c'est éventuellement de prendre
pied en france et ensuite ces deux
normaliser le même film dans le monde
entier dont il ya peu de chance en effet
que soit la culture française qui s'en
sort mais si vous réussissez à garder ou
à faire émerger ou empêcher disparaître
des groupes qui ont cette volonté
moi je pense que vous réussirez parce
que nous avons une vraie richesse et que
je pense que les talents et les
résultats se conjuguent
universal music c'est à la fois des
talents formidables et les résultats et
moi je pense que canal vivendi peut
faire la même chose lagardère regarder
lagardère tout le monde parle de
lagardère
c'est intéressant peut-être de regarder
ce groupe moi j'ai bien connu jean luc
lagardère il a laissé à son fils arnaud
une situation compliquée puisqu'il
n'avait que 5 % du capital quelque chose
comme ça et il avait fait une commandite
qui est un organisation qui est à la
fois un château fort mais pas
complètement indestructible qu'est ce
qu'il a à faire nous lagardère la
première chose qu'il a faite quand il a
pris la suite de son père il s'est
endetté pour acheter des actions pour
montrer à ses équipes et au monde entier
qu'il avait confiance et qui voulait
développer ce groupe c'est courageux de
le faire
ils se retrouvent ensuite
avec
une pandémie qui touche un secteur très
important et pourtant je vous dis il a
été courageux il a été engagé il a
internationalisé parce que l'essentiel
vachette c'est pas la france s'est à
nouveau l'international moi je pense à
fait partie des groupes qu'il faut
soutenir ce qu'a fait l'état d'ailleurs
avec le pg e à un moment
et c'est ce que nous faisons c'est le
soutien d'arnaud lagardère de son groupe
et sa politique donc est-ce que ça doit
être les pouvoirs publics qu'ils font
est-ce que ça doit être des fonds privés
je ne sais pas mais ce sont ces groupes
qui créeront demain la richesse de la
france arnaud lagardère peux vous dire
on habite au même endroit il aime ce
pays donc on a intérêt plutôt à les
sauver aider des gens comme ça plutôt
que des étrangers qui viennent et qui
vous dit bonjour qui sont très aimables
et puis dans deux ans vous les verrez
plus jamais et moi je suis très
impressionné sur la chronologie des
médias qui est une chose vous parlez des
mesures à prendre c'est quand même
quelque chose d'extraordinaire on est en
train d'ouvrir la porte à des grandes
plateformes
c'est formidable où amazon avec le foot
on est obligé d'ouvrir la porte je vous
dis à nouveau le groupe vivendi
s'adaptera voilà 200 ans dans les pattes
on en fera sans doute quelques années de
plus encore mais
votre rôle à mon avis et voilà c'est
notre pays les étrangers défendent leur
pays les allemands regarder ce que font
les allemands regardent et bertelsmann
vous parliez tout à l'heure des delà de
la concentration
des gens qui travaillaient les uns avec
les autres j'ai un slide là-dessus qui
est assez intéressant qui est le dise si
vous voulez bien le passé monsieur voilà
regardez les groupes ils sont tous dans
le tv édition presse radio autre nom le
dise
voilà voilà répartition du chiffre
d'affaires par activité
oui ils sont tous à travailler ensemble
mais sont pas dans les ports en afrique
non mais d'abord écouter partout des
mois comme vous savez on est obligé d'en
sortir donc je le regrette d'ailleurs
parce que je pense que c'est un
continent qui est à nos portes
il va y avoir deux milliards d'habitants
c'est la chine de demain voilà donc je
regrette qu'on ait été
malheureusement
obligés de partir mais ces jeux
pardonnez moi non mais attendez je
comprends ce que vous direz qu'on vous
dise le btp cd groupe de presse allemand
franchement est ce que on peut pas dire
que voilà que j'essaye de favoriser
monsieur bouygues au cours d'une
commission mais enfin je vois pas ce que
c'est un français qui est très bien qui
gère ses affaires remarquablement bien
lui aussi est arrivé avec une situation
un peu complexe y'a rien à lui reprocher
peut-être bon c'est pas un gros prix
s'est internationalisé mais je ne vois
pas
j'ai moi personnellement problème et je
ne rejoins je parle pas votre choix
précise je précise vous donner un
exemple qui est les groupes allemands et
leurs investissements importants et leur
grandeur dans le domaine des médias et
de la presse oui
avec une particularité c'est que ce sont
des veaux de médias et de presse etc en
france sont des investisseurs qui
viennent d'autres mondes et j'ai cité le
band le btp etc c'est pareil dans les
autres pays des maps en italie c'est
pareil le groupe berlusconi a fait
beaucoup d'autres choses que de la
presse le groupe caltagirone dans le
bâtiment etc partout dans le monde
mon avis sur le sur le le plan la
constitution des groupes moi je le vois
qu'il ya un point dans votre stratégie
que j'ai du mal à suivre c'est pourquoi
laisser partir universal music jeu il ya
cinq ans vous nous expliquer ici même
que
avoir universal music était un élément
extrêmement fort du groupe et on
comprend parfaitement en plus c'est un
des leaders mondiaux dans son secteur et
là on voit bien dans la dans la vision
de vivendi aujourd'hui vous mettez sur
le
cd des actions d'universal music le
remettre sur le marché
quelle est l'idée derrière le fait que
vous quittiez cet univers de la musique
avec un leader mondial existants comme
universal music alors le groupe bolloré
n'a pas du tout quitté universal music
où on a toujours les 320 millions
d'actions d'universal music qu'on avait
il ya cinq ans et qu'on a aujourd'hui on
en a pas vendu une seule mais un certain
nombre d actionnaires de vivendi qui
sont blackrock legal and général pisam
et autres fonds elliott il y en a qui
disait ça vaudra beaucoup moins d'autres
qui disait ça vaudra beaucoup plus et
ils ont demandé depuis que nous sommes
arrivés depuis le premier jour à ce que
les activités soient séparés mais nous
en tant que groupe bolloré nous avons le
même pourcentage dans le groupe
universal qu en arrivant donc nous ne
l'avons pas lâcher d'où l'intérêt à
favoriser c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure ou en tout cas ne pas nuire pour
des groupes français qui ont envie de
continuer à se développer parce que la
vérité c'est que vivendi comme je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure l'essentiel du
capital il est détenu par des fonds
étrangers
70% du capital de vivendi +2 70% du
capital de vivendi est détenue par des
fonds qui si demain matin canal+ ne
marche pas ou dailymotion et vendus par
orange ne lèveront pas le petit doigt
parce que ça ne les intéresse pas alors
qu'à mon avis yannick bolloré arnault
puis fontaine
jean christophe thiery et autres ils
sont français ils ont envie de continuer
d aventure enfants tout cas c'est ce que
j'espère j'ai essayé de bâtir ma
succession pour que justement il est
sept affectio societatis qui a fait
qu'on a réussi à tenir deux cents ans ça
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'entreprises dans
le monde qui sont capables de rester 200
ans malgré deux guerres mondiales
plusieurs révolutions des évolutions
techniques des disputes familiales tout
ce que voulait des évolutions de
produits et qui sont toujours au même
endroit et à développer le même pays
bonjour monsieur bolloré je voudrais
vous faire part à mon tour de trois
motifs d'inquiétude ou trois questions
j'ai proposé la première depuis le début
de l'audition vous employez à vous
présenter comme un groupe
modest pas si important que ça
en vérité quand on regarde un peu le
paysage où il ya très peu d'acteurs dans
le paysage
l'information est dans le paysage
audiovisuel français aujourd'hui en
dehors du service public
cinq six groupes contrôlent maintenant
bientôt l'essentiel donc en fait vous
êtes un des acteurs importants
aujourd'hui contraints - ce que vous
dites on a parlé d' havas vous savez
bien que la publicité par exemple est
une question pas seulement marcher c'est
une question stratégique pour la survie
de beaucoup de titres
cédés points qui sont quand même assez
stratégique dans la situation mais à
propos de la de cette question il ya une
chose sur lesquels vous n'avez rien dit
c'est quelles sont vos appétits futur
vous êtes ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
vous avez grossi dans la dernière
période
est ce que vous voulez grossir j'ai
compris en creux dans votre discours que
c'était votre ambition
donc jusqu'où vous pensez que un groupe
peut aller de la part de contrôle dans
un secteur comme celui là sans mettre en
cause
les principes du pluralisme
de la diversité de la création ça c'est
ma première question la seconde second
motif d'inquiétude c'est sur le modèle
vous dites mon projet économique et moi
j'ai un critère en fait d'où l'avait
répété à plusieurs reprises c'est la
rentabilité mais et vous dites je veux
devenir un champion de la culture
française et européenne ce que vous avez
dit dans le propos liminaire
mais la culture française et européenne
singulièrement la culture française
c'est pas seulement la rentabilité l'âme
au sol parce que si c'était ça il n'y
aurait pas justement la diversité
actuelle de il s'agit pas de faire des
queues des groupes qui perdent de
l'argent mais je prends un exemple qui
évidemment l'intérêt par rapport à canal
le cinéma français
si nous avions copier les américains il
ya 20 ou 30 ans il y aurait plus de
cinéma français est probablement plus de
cinéma un repère pour ce qu'il en est
nous avons inventé en france un modèle
original et qui ne s'est pas appuyé
seulement sur des champions qui
s'appuyait sur des politiques publiques
la taxation des billets etc on a créé un
écosystème qui a permis et il ya des
acteurs y compris privés qui ont joué ce
jeu là qui ont accepté ces règles et qui
au nom justement de la culture
françaises ont joué un rôle tout
particulier vous avez cité jean luc
lagardère il se trouve que dans une
autre vie puisque dès qu on a presque
quelques années je l' ai connu aussi la
gale jean luc lagardère a par exemple
porté à bout de bras j'dirais pendant
des années le système de distribution
mutualisé de la presse française et pas
pour des raisons de rentabilité
mais par attachement à une certaine
conception du pluralisme
lorsque j'entends dans votre modèle
j'entends pas beaucoup ce à quoi donc
j'entends plutôt un modèle qui
ressemblerait à ce que est ce que font
les américains et je suis pas sûr que en
matière culturelle puisque vous dites
être un champion de la culture française
européenne ce soit l'eau modèle
qui soit le modèle le plus pertinent
pour porter justement la culture
française ou la culture européenne où
les valeurs qu'on a supporté et enfin
une dernière remarque je m'excuse de
revenir là dessus mais puisque vous avez
cessé venu plusieurs fois à propos de
eric zemmour
et puisque vous avez fait référence jeu
je dois dire que je m'étonne que vous
banalisez cette question d'autant plus
que vous avez fait référence en parlant
de notre histoire familiale à la
résistance
il se trouve que je suis d'une famille
politique qui est assez sensible à cette
question aussi
à
moi j'ai une grand-mère qui
figure parmi les justes parler parmi les
nations parce qu'elle a sauvé des
enfants juifs qu'elle a risqué sa vie
pour ça
non eric zemmour c'est pas une opinion
comme une autre
hier c'est la troisième fois qu'il est
condamné pour incitation à la haine
raciale
et quand il a fait les déclarations
qu'il a fait sur la question de vichy
oui c'est un problème pour la démocratie
française
donc prendre la responsabilité
évidemment il a son opinion il ya des
français qui peuvent conseil comme l'i
et il y en a malheureusement fait ce te
ment
mais prendre la responsabilité
de lui
de lui donner de la place éditoriale
c'est pas c'est pas comme une autre pour
nous ou alors sinon ça veut dire que les
jugements répété
à son égard sur la question du racisme
ne compte pour rien mais en démocratie
c'est je crois qu'on peut peut-être
tombés d'accord sur l'idée que le
racisme n'est pas une opinion comme une
autre c'est un délit
donc je crois que sur cette question je
je je crois que la banalisation
n'est pas n'est pas acceptable
sur cette troisième question vous
connaissez le mot
attribuée à voltaire je crois justement
make me répétait un ami je ne partage
pas vos idées mais je me battrai pour
que vous puissiez les exprimer
en ce qui concerne voilà vous voyez je
vous montrerai après que personnelle que
j'ai qui est un petit mot du général de
gaulle à mon père
à michel bolloré en souvenir de notre
combat commun
voilà donc je pense que sur le plan de
la démocratie et du reste voilà j'ai un
adn qui va bien
je vous dis monsieur zemmour il était
sur toutes les autres chaînes il était
encore qu'on est on l'a retiré de ses
news il est chez bfm tous les soirs
je voudrais savoir pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que c'est uniquement sur
chez nous que ça porte vous recevez les
gens de bfm ou leur en parlez vous leur
demandez pourquoi ils viennent comment
ça se passe et ce qu'il a le droit de
s'exprimer ou pas ils savent bien
monsieur bolloré parce que vous avez
bien sûr vous ne connaissez pas je le
dis a beaucoup d'essais sans dire que
j'essaye de vous dire que dans le groupe
canal et dans ce que nous sommes en
train de bâtir le fait politique ne
représente même pas 1% donc on peut
parvenir indéfiniment à dire que tout ce
qu'on construit c'est pour des raisons
politiques c'est pas la réalité c'est
pas la réalité des fêtes de la même
façon que c'est par la réalité des fêtes
qu'on est tout puissant vous les montre
et on est tout petit mais
de même nous ne sommes pas à la
recherche uniquement de rentabilité je
me suis mal exprimé auprès de vous parce
que ce que j'ai dit c'est qu'au
contraire je pense qu'il faut aller vers
les comptes vers les talents mais que ça
n'est pas incompatible d'avoir de la
rentabilité parce que toute façon si ya
pas de rentabilité un moment ou un autre
aura plus de talent il y aura plus de
contenu qui pourront continuer mais bon
vous me dites
la culture française on l'a protégé mais
attendez vous êtes en train de détruire
avec la chronologie des médias tout ce
que vous avez fait pour protéger le
cinéma qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient canal
avait du succès avec son cinéma c'est
parce que il fallait attendre deux ans
sur les plateformes étrangères ou trois
ans de plus qu'elle est et défis pour
aller voir les films américains et les
films français vous allez voir
maintenant pratiquement en même temps
sur canal dont vous êtes pardonnez-moi à
nouveau je vous dis canal se
débrouillera mais vous pouvez pas dire à
la fois on protège c'est grâce à nous et
à la fois prendre des mesures que vous
êtes en train de prendre vous prenez
exactement le contraire de ce qu'il faut
pour aider le cinéma français mais moi
je vous dis vous détruire et le cinéma
français parce qu'il n'y aura plus à ce
moment là même si vous avez des
plateformes que 5 ou 10 films par an
important qui seront financées par les
plateformes alors que nous on n'en
finance 250 par an enfin nous canal
sur la suite et la fin
moi je ne veux pas grossir moi mon
ambition c'est de fêter le 17 février le
bicentaire du groupe et ergué gabéric
avec ceux qui me succède si je peux y
aller avec l'épidémie qui espère
mes successeurs
que je connais puisque c'est j'ai
contribué beaucoup elle est nommée et ça
là dessus je ne me dérobe pas non plus
les gens qui seront en poste sont des
gens voilà alors
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire derrière
j'espère leur avoir poussé à essayer de
défendre cette culture française et moi
en tout cas quand je les entends parler
devant moi
il disent tous voila c'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire
mais c'est vrai que vous disiez toute la
france seuls sénateurs on prend des
coups tout le temps c'est vrai
voilà moi j'ai la peau un peu abîmée
comme les vieux sembliez donc c'est pas
agréable mais je fais avec mes des
jeunes qui arrivent
c'est un peu compliqué de faire des
procès d'intention
sur des réalités qui n'en sont pas
forcément
alors voilà j'espère que ça continuera
et je vous remercie en tout cas beaucoup
de m'avoir reçus et écoutés encore trop
à vous voulez me sens moi je reste au
temps de jeu je précise juste que la
chronologie des médias ne dépend pas du
parlement mais interprofessionnelle
valider ou pas par le gouvernement donc
la cornée vincent capo-canellas ce merci
président merci monsieur bolloré
vous êtes un grand capitaine d'industrie
vous avez affiché tout à l'heure des
objectifs de rayonnement culturel de la
france à l'international
vous avez enfin dit que vous êtes
démocrate chrétien et je ne peux qu'être
sensible à ça pas seulement au dernier
point d'ailleurs alors les démocrates
chrétiens savent que les copies que
l'une marché c'est la base et sont aussi
soucieux d'équilibrer rejet trois
questions
première question en termes d' équilibre
économique parce que vous pensez que les
médias audiovisuels devrait pouvoir
évoluer vers des médias d'opinion un peu
comme la presse écrite
et que ça leur permettrait de mieux
trouver leur public et donc peut-être de
mieux assurer leur indépendance
premier la première question ce que les
médias donc aller vers des médias
d'opinion deuxièmement quand vous voyez
l'exemple de télés étrangères comme
foxnews qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
et enfin troisièmement sur le choix des
éditorialistes on a compris tout à
l'heure que vient alors une capacité de
détection enfin en tout cas de toux de
choix de talents aujourd'hui dans un
monde où on voit bien que c'est la
culture du clash qui marche dans les
médias et donc on va plutôt vers des
éditorialistes clivant
alors qu'ils n'ont pas faim client qui
est aussi parfois heureux
apporte aussi une logique d'opinion mais
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que on
manque aujourd'hui d'analystes qui soit
aussi moins clivant qui donnerait
justement une notion d' équilibre
laquelle les démocrates chrétiens sont
sensibles
écoutez moi je regarde pas beaucoup la
télévision pour tout vous dire donc
j'entends de l'extérieur ce qui se passe
sur les chaînes et les sujets etc mais
j'ai pas quoi vous dire sur ce qui se
passe à l'étranger en tout cas il ya un
point que se partagent avec le
rapporteur sénateur david assouline
c'est que tant que ce sont des
fréquences hertziennes qui appartiennent
à l'état
l'état doit avoir un contrôle absolu et
je ne vois pas d'intérêt d'aller créer
des chaînes d'opinion moi
personnellement voilà c'est un avis
personnel tant que vous avez c'est votre
fréquence et des fréquences de l'état
l'état doit gérer et dire ce qu'il veut
ce qu'il veut pas
moi j'ai pas l'impression de faire des
chaînes d'opinion soit quelque chose de
positif mais honnêtement j'y connais pas
grand chose parce que vous l'avez vu on
ne représente que 0,1 pour cent des
trucs d'opinion nous je peux vous parler
du cinéma je peux vous parler du sport
si vous voulez je peux vous parler des
séries
sur le plan de l'info c'est un peu plus
compliqué et sur l'étranger je ne
connais pas bien non plus
parce que je ne regarde pas la
télévision étrangère et je ne sais pas
comment ça marche
moi je vois arriver dès des immenses
groupes qui sont pour l'essentiel des
plateformes
et je pense que ce sont ceux là les
dangers et vous savez les invasions à
partir du vème siècle on a vu arriver
des très gros et on a cru que c'étaient
les plus gros pas du tout ils fuyaient
devant des gens encore plus gros et moi
je les connais les plus gros parce que
j'ai travaillé avec eux et
sont des groupes très fort les
américains avec les droits de vote
multiples ce sont des personnes qui
possèderont moi même quand j'étais
président chez vivendi
j'ai été obligé de tenir compte des
actionnaires extérieurs parce que
j'étais pas majoritaires mais les
groupes que vous allez voir arriver
qu'ils sont en train d'arriver sont des
groupes américains avec des majoritaires
avec des droits de vote multiples qui ne
sont pas autorisés en france ou des
asiatiques avec une vision politique
très claire
comment se défendre de ça je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas
jean-pierre vers genève
monsieur bolloré moi je voulais vous
poser une question à plusieurs questions
mais je vais aller très très vite
revenir sur le slate qui est passé tout
à l'heure c'est sur la taille entre les
gars femmes et les médias français
et c 17 un document qu'on nous montre
que les médias français nous montre
souvent et je voulais savoir si dans la
réalité de l'action quotidienne de votre
groupe vous considérez que ce soit
réellement vos concurrents au delà même
de la taille déjà juste peut-être par la
nature des métiers alors ça peut frotter
sur le foot ou des choses comme ça mais
est ce que ce sont réellement vos
concurrents au quotidien est ce que ce
ne sont pas plutôt les groupes qui sont
sur l'autre salaï les axel springer les
bertelsmann donc ma question
premièrement c'est qu'ils sont vos vrais
concurrents et deuxièmement votre avis
sur le rapprochement tf1 m6 qui est un
des sujets qui a participé à créer cette
commission
tf1 m6 qui nous disent ne sent rien au
slide il faut qu'on se regroupe pour
être plus forts et concurrencer les gars
femme est ce que vous croyez à la
réalité de cet argument ou est ce que
vous pensez qu on est plutôt sur deux
entreprises qui sont sur un métier qui
font que les amis avec des habitudes de
consommation qui change qui font qu'il
ya un besoin de se regrouper pourquoi
pas d'ailleurs pour que baisser les
coûts de fonctionnement et maintenir les
marges
et pensez vous que ce rapprochement est
de nature à bousculer le marché je parle
notamment des pubs la répartition des
richesses qui aurait sur le marché
pensez vous que cela peut avoir des
conséquences sur les médias français
nous ne concurrençons ce que je vous ai
indiqué sur le sur le style sur le
tableau d'où nos concurrents sont ceux
qui viennent faire des plates formes de
cinéma ou de séries donc c'est apple
c'est amazon vous savez que amazon vous
êtes amazon prime dès que vous achetez
après ce légume à 24 euros vous êtes
table automatiquement amazon prime et
vous avez tous les contenus gratos de
toutes les séries et tous les films donc
bon apple vous avez vu ce qu'ils font
netflix va vous avez vu aussi le
développement qu'ils ont et
donc nous nos concurrents c'est ce que
je vous ai indiqué c'est pas bertelsmann
et axel springer
tf1 m6 la différence avec nous c'est que
tf1 m6 ce sont des groupes français dont
l'essentiel de leur activité est en
france nous on est un groupe pardon on
est des regains gabéric
on est français
mais l'essentiel notre activité est à
l'étranger
c'est un rayonnement étrangers
est ce que ça vient poser des problèmes
je suis pas le mieux placé pour répondre
franchement j'en sais rien je vous dis
c'est plus je ne suis pas en concurrence
il faudrait recevoir banide g qu'on a
essayé d'aider
offres qu'on va aider grâce à nous vive
un dj a réussi à devenir le numéro un
mondial des des programmes de flux on a
apporté les centaines de millions
nécessaires qu' il n'aurait pas trouvé
sinon et qui n'auraient pas pu faire
mais moi je peux pas vous répondre parce
que je connais pas bien la télé gratuite
française claudie sur la télé gratuite
française on est insignifiant
chaque ligne de stats brigneau qu'il est
derrière son écran
merci monsieur le président monsieur
bolloré j'ai évidemment entendu tout ce
que vous avez dit depuis que vous avez
commencé cette audition alors mon
collègue se donnait à a dit au tout
début de ces propos que des gens qui
réussissent elles dans notre pays
entraîner soit le respect soit la
suspicion cas moi je voulais vous dire
que vous avez tout mon respect je tenais
à le dire vraiment parce que voilà des
hommes qui se construisent et des hommes
qui font travailler des milliers
d'autres hommes je pense que on doit
leur donner on doit dire le respect
lorsque en tout cas c'est mon cas moi je
voudrais je voulais voilà vous avez dit
également monsieur bolloré que vous ne
faisiez pas politique mais nous on en
fait et autour cette table les sénateurs
qui vous entourent ou qui le regardent
en visio font de la politique donc cette
commission enquête elle a un objectif
c'est de se poser la question sur la
concentration des médias
voilà un certain nombre d'auditions en
tout cas on a entendu à plusieurs
reprises que pour
voilà certain nombre de chercheurs ou de
gens qui réfléchissent aise sur un ca
sur ce sujet ce n'était pas un souci ce
n'était pas un problème mais j'ai écouté
aussi tous les collègues sénateurs pour
un certain nombre de sénateurs c'est une
vraie question de remise en cause
probable de la démocratie et d'ailleurs
je vous le dis je voulais dire monsieur
le président de la commission il ya des
propos ont été tenus aujourd'hui qui me
choque beaucoup qui ne sont pas du tout
liés à l'audition de monsieur bolloré je
pense que les procès d'intention sont
pas toujours très sains dans les
commissions c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs que je le dit lors d'une
commission d' enquête ou d'une
commission d'information
il ya des propos qui n'ont aucun rapport
avec la mission de notre commission
d'enquêté je voulais le dire voilà bon
je pense que c'était important tout cas
pour moi c'est important que je le dise
et certains de mes collègues aussi
sénateurs ont sans arrêt si les mesures
immo moi je lui aucun souci je ne suis
pas une fanatique du tout de ces mots
mais tout comme monsieur mélenchon le
céser mort à droite parlent et je pense
que c'est l'honneur de notre démocratie
et de notre diversité d'opinion que de
pouvoir exprimer les choses qui sont
juste l'expression de français
malheureusement parfois il faut aussi se
poser la question suivante rôle de
politique quand on en arrive à avoir
d'eric zemmour qui font de tels scores
dans les sondages ça nous pose de nous
poser des questions plutôt qu'à la
presse moi je voulais aussi revenir je
voulais avoir votre peut-être avis même
si vous nous avait expliqué que vous
n'étiez pas directement impliqué dans
l'organisation
des faits l'action et du recrutement des
journalistes que je crois on se pose
beaucoup aujourd'hui la question de la
concentration des grands groupes en ce
qui concerne les médias on se pose
jamais la question d'ailleurs du
pluralisme du service public comme ça ça
pose deux questions personne moi je me
pose la question du pluralisme dans un
avis public peut-être ça fera l'objet
d'une autre commission alors deux
petites questions mais peut-être deux
petites réflexions que vous rien nous
donner monsieur bolloré s'est d'abord à
ce que vous pensez que dans les médias
il ya les outils suffisants
pour préserver celle ce pluralisme
nécessaire kelly à notre démocratie a
vraiment ça je pense que c'est important
est ce que moi c'est qu'il ya les outils
suffisants
pense que c'est important et est ce que
vous pensez qu'on se pose les mêmes
questions de pluralisme pour le service
public qui je le rappelle fonctionne
avec l'argent des citoyens avec l'argent
des français donc est-ce qu'on se pose
les mêmes questions selon vous est-ce
que la suspicion est plutôt faite sur un
écran groupe privé voilà merci monsieur
le président merci pour vos propos aussi
agréable madame la sénatrice merci
beaucoup moi je trouve qu'il ya le
pluralisme à titre personnel mais je
vous dis je suis pas un consommateur de
télévision énorme parce que mes journées
commencent très tôt finissent très tard
et j'ai malheureusement pas le temps
quoique
my canal est un outil informatique
formidable digital qui permet de
récupérer un peu plus tard mais même
s'il rentre à 20h30 et que après avoir
mangé rapidement je le regardais il me
reste une heure une heure et demie deux
heures maximum donc j'ai pas le temps
d'absorber tout ça moi j'ai le sentiment
que notre pays il ya le pluralisme j'ai
l'impression tout le monde peut
s'exprimer que l'on voit là on aider on
est des gaulois part il faut pas le dire
non plus mais enfin bon bon
chacun chacun exprime ce qu'il a à le
dire et moi je trouve qu'il ya sous le
bleu pluralisme et honnêtement sur le
service public j'ai rien à dire de
particulier c'est vrai que
moi en tant que paratonnerre j'ai vu
passer toutes les critiques possibles
voilà
c'est vrai que
le truc me concernant si on faisait une
revue de presse si on faisait les mêmes
calculs qu'il y avait été fait pour
savoir si
havas mais plus de publicité sur nos
chaînes et qu'on dit est ce que le
service public dit plus de mâles du
groupe bolloré que de bien sans doute il
y aurait des pourcentages mais c'est la
démocratie c'est comme ça il faut
l'accepter moi je suis pas là pour qu'on
me dresse des couronnes de fleurs même
si ça fait très plaisir merci beaucoup
madame la sénatrice j'essaye simplement
de rétablir des fêtes qui sont que voilà
il n'y a pas de dans le groupe canal et
c'est pour ça que s'il motorisés sur le
président j'aimerais bien quand même
passé mon petit truc de deux minutes si
monsieur le rapporteur veut bien et on
fera les questions après n'en voulait
pas bon allez vous les avez les fils
avons alors attendez c'est peut-être sur
une autre
peut-être que
vous pouvez nous l'envoyer ce sera un
document crd six essieux pas
forcément dans les salles de projection
n'est pas rien de ce c'était pour
montrer en résumé que voilà sur les
antennes de canal pendant que j'en étais
président et pendant que c'était la
période la plus dure tout le monde
s'amusait à dire du mal de moi sur les
antennes de canal et qu'il n'y avait pas
de sujet
dont je dis ça je dis ça c'est pas bien
rebondir s'il est sur dur attentes oui
alors justement
vous avez
montré encore ce soir que vous avez
aussi le sens de l'humour mais
sauf quand ils s'exercent à votre
encontre
ou même pas votre encontre d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas apprécié les guignols de
l'info vous ne l'avez pas reconduit en
2018 il ya une anecdote pouvait
peut-être pour l'anecdote le confirmer
mais à un moment donné vous aviez émis
l'idée dit-on d'écrire vous même les
sketches
des guignols
licenciement d'europe 1 de bertrand
chamerois le 2 juillet 2020 après une
chronique vous concernant tu t'es
d'ailleurs une chronique plutôt réussie
au demeurant
licenciement surprenant de sébastien
thoen de canal+ en novembre 2020 pour
une parodie de leurs des pros
émissions phares de ces news
licenciement de stéphane guillon
franchement
de la même chaîne parce que il a déclaré
soutenir et s'étonner du licenciement de
sébastien thoen
départ de nicolas canteloup d'europe 1
après une chronique vous concernant donc
la question c'est un peu pour conclure
vous avez développé des raisons
profondes de votre investissement dans
les médias votre vision
cela c'est c'est l'objet même de nos
débats et de l'analyse au fond que l'on
doit voir parce que ce que vous avez
développé à votre façon c'est ce que
d'autres qui se concentre aussi des
médias il faut avec des puissants
supérieure à la vôtre
disent en gros cette histoire des
plateformes dégâts femmes des chinois
aussi et qu'il faut des grands gros pour
pouvoir assurer la concurrence pour
défendre la france vous ajoutez vous et
la culture française vous n'avez pas
défini pour vous ce qu'est la culture
française mais en tous les cas c'est ce
que vous affirmez et quand on vous
projetez vous même les les graphiques
pour nous montrer
la taille des uns et des autres et
justement c'est ce qui est pas
convaincant mais on va continuer nous à
travailler là dessus pour répondre à
cette question c'est que si c'est pour
résister aux la fable quand apple fait
15 milliards en une année et je parle
pas de nec fit amazon et tous les autres
et que tout l'audiovisuel français vous
mais aussi le service public tf1 m6 etc
font 5 milliards d'investissements en
cinq ans la concurrence en terme de
puissance financière et capacités de
production
sont dérisoires que vous avez dit vous
même il ya les nains bon face à des gens
et donc la résistance
la défense de nos valeurs plus que
seulement la culture française nos
valeurs républicaines
c'est un modèle qu'on a construit avec
des régulations pour que la diversité et
le pluralisme
d'indépendance la liberté des médias les
diffusions culturelles la création
puisse être toujours là et donc c'est
pour cela c'était
assez fastidieux probablement que j'ai
lu l'ensemble
de ce que vous contrôlez
c'était long mais ça montre est quand
même que sur le terrain français cette
diversité risque d'être appauvri quand
c'est un même propriétaire
qui contrôlent quasiment toutes les
maisons d'édition et donc quand on lit
des livres on sait que le propriétaire
ou quand on veut faire un livre est bien
s'il ne veut pas ou si il veux favoriser
telle lecture et bien et d'un pouvoir il
en abuse ou pas mais il a un pouvoir
c'est pareil pour la télé c'est pareil
pour la radio c'est pareil pour la
presse écrite et donc il faudrait
accepter se dire pourvu que le
propriétaire n'abuse pas de ce pouvoir
et
vous vous avez c'est nous convaincre que
vous n'intervenez pas et vous n'abusez
jamais de ce pouvoir
or
les faits puisque vous m'avez interpellé
sur les faits montrent que quand une
rédaction
n'est pas d'accord
on lui on lui fait prendre la porte qu'
il y à des interventions pour nommer des
gens en général
de la même
école ou école de pensée on va dire même
si vous dites vous fait pas de politique
mais personne aujourd'hui ne peut
ignorer ce que sont les faits de tous
ceux qui sont nommés et ce que l'on
entend sur des antennes que l'on entend
par ailleurs et sur le pluralisme parce
que bien entendu on auditionnera le
service public et toutes les questions
seront les bienvenues sur l'indépendance
le pluralisme de tous les médias --y
compris service public mais
très franchement
je vous ai parlé de faits
quant à europe 1 la rédaction d'i on
peut plus travailler avec notre liberté
dont coupât quant à itélé c'est le cas
bien entendu qui a le même nombre
d'employés qui vient derrière et il n'y
a pas de perte sèche mais les cette
liberté qui existe des rédactions et de
du travail journalistique
vous êtes un interventionniste assez
direct
vous dit non et bien
voilà nous sommes dans une commission d
enquête où il se sert comme sur les
joints nettement sur europe 1 je n'ai vu
aucun journaliste donc je ne sais même
pas comment vous pouvez affirmer que
j'ai fait partir des journalistes non
mais personne ne m'a vu danser la
réputation qui est fait oui non mais
c'est la vérité c'est ça c'est la
réputation qui est fait donc fait que je
finis ma question tout est fantasque
tout eréputation alors c'est vrai
je vous l'aurais que nous savons que
dans le domaine des médias l'autocensure
par crainte par pas vouloir
10 ont
suscité le courroux
d'un actionnaire existe mais
voilà en tous les cas que vous disiez
ici que vous vous souciez en rien de la
ligne éditorial et des contenus des
médias que vous possédez ne m'a pas
convaincu et vous avez ce qu'ils versent
un nombre de questions qui vous
interpellez concrètement là dessus celle
que je viens de dire c'est
encore tous ses départs
d'humoristes ou deux personnes qui ont
osé vous critiquez
a bien sûr voilà non mais écoutez je
reviens en arrière on va laisser ça à
monsieur pleurer c'est pas votre juste
c'est pas votre adn pions en question on
a tous un adn est donc un respect absolu
pour l'histoire de votre famille pour la
résistance et
vraiment absolue mais c'est d'autant
plus étonnant moi je ne vous connais pas
personnellement et on m'a toujours
raconter votre histoire familiale ce qui
est très étonnant c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer sur des antennes que
vous possédez et monsieur pierre laurent
l'a évoqué ce ne sont pas des valeurs de
la république et donc ce n'est pas une
question simple de pluralisme mais
d'actes délictueux qui sont condamnés
par la justice et vous nous avez à aucun
moment dans l'audition dit que vous
condamnez comme la justice l'a fait
les propos d'eric zemmour qui sont en
question voyez-vous l'hérésie répondre
que jamais dans la gestion vous nous
allons refaire que vous condamnez en
forme de conclusion je vous laisse
répondre sinon mais ios cabot pardon
d'abord sur les gars femmes etc j'ai pas
dit qu'il fallait nous défendre contre
les gars femmes j'ai dit qu'on se
débrouillerait tout mon audition c'était
pour expliquer au contraire qu on
s'adaptera et j'ai expliqué qu'au cours
des 200 dernières années on s'est adapté
la guerre a arrêté les usines enfin bref
pas m'arrêter là dessus voilà le groupe
s'adaptera donc je vous ai pas demandé
de nous protéger simplement je dis vous
êtes en train de faire exactement le
contraire après si c'est votre choix par
nature moi je suis démocrate chrétien
assurément et démocrates assurément et
donc si c'est votre choix vous êtes élu
du peuple si c'est votre choix de ouvrir
la porte aux gars femmes pour détruire
canal c'est moi la limite vous faites ce
que vous voulez pichana l'ira se
débrouillera s'adaptera ce qui fait
d'ailleurs à travers ma et canal est ce
qui fait dans les alliances puisque
maintenant nous distribuons netflix et
nous sommes aussi en distributeur de
binh donc on peut pas faire autrement
donc si vous voulez nous on n'est pas du
tout à venir dire aidez nous aidez nous
on dit simplement primum no serré si on
pouvait avoir quand on parle de tf1 m6
là aussi ce vous décider souverainement
mais il faut pas qu'il y ait deux poids
deux mesures c'est la seule chose que je
dis sur l'ensemble après sur les fêtes
sur notre taille et en particulier sur
notre taille dans l'intervention
politique c'est incontestable vous et
montrez on est tout petit
alors on fait beaucoup de bruit autour
de nous mais on est encore tout petit
est ce qu'on va grandir j'en sais rien
c'est pas moi c'est mes successeurs je
l'espère
sur le reste moi je pense que la liberté
d'expression est quelque chose de très
important que toutes les expressions à
ma connaissance on sur le groupe met à
nouveau je vous redis sur canal vous
nous faites un procès comme si on était
tf1 ou l'a6 où l'aca compte ce qu'ils
disent et les gens qui passent sur leurs
antennes nous dans le temps d'antenne
regardé par les gens
99.99 je vous redis c'est des sports
mécaniques c'est du cinéma donc on vient
nous chercher sur quelque chose qui est
voilà et quant à eric zemmour je vous
redis il passe sur l'a6 ils passent dans
le figaro je moi je et il était sur i
télé avant que j'arrive donc je veux
dire moi je veux bien être le père
d'eric zemmour putatif comme vous me le
présenter mais enfin quand même voilà et
puis quand on écrit que je lui téléphone
tous les jours je déjeune tous les mois
avec lui si je dis rien on dit c'est que
c'est vrai et si je fais un procès en
disant c'est pas vrai sur quoi vous
basez vous ont dit je fais des procès
bâillon voilà une fois que j'ai dit que
j'assumais des paratonnerres j'assume
des paratonnerres voilà et je vous redis
je pense que vous allez recevoir les
dirigeants du groupe canal vous allez
recevoir j'espère les dirigeants de
vivendi je pense que vous avez là un
groupe patriotes français dynamique et
j'espère qu'il continuera
merci à jour merci infiniment merci
monsieur bolloré d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors désolé pour la vidéo on
a un problème de forme mais pas grasse
est pas mauvais alors celle des toiles
d'entrée au rapportera souligne que sur
les faits mme tout le monde se moque de
moi et que ils sont encore là mais nous
le regardons
[Musique]